ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
anh alo
ờ ờ
anh đợi mình mình đăng bài chắc đã có
một bạn xem rồi
ừ ừ
à à
ăn
đu đủ mâm chữ y được không ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ thế là người đã chọn trong mọi thứ đó
hay sao
cho bố mà rủ
a word nhanh fake
smack Mọi khi mình 7 chữ mình cũng bắt
đầu nữa
anh không Hôm nay bây giờ thì đang không
mưa đâu
ờ ờ
Mình tranh thủ ngủ mình sang thủ và phim
sớm để mình tranh thủ trả lời một vài
câu họ đứng trước mình mà ra hôm trước
thì các bạn cả buổi tối các bạn thành
đạt câu hỏi gì mấy con mỗi có sau này từ
lâu lắm rồi
ý tưởng trước câu này thì mình sẽ phát
nhường cho hôm 15 mình sẽ trả lời à
Cho mình xin mấy trả lời 2 câu này Hôm
nay một cái câu thì bạn đấy hỏi là mình
dạy về uux
ờ ờ
để
đó để cuối cuối buổi hôm nay các bạn
nhiều nhất mình nhé mình sẽ chia sẻ các
bạn một cái bài về with rất hay mà mình
từng từng đọc ở trên cũng ở trên kia Bao
Loc mình mình đứng yên à Bởi vì mình đặt
nên là kiến thức đấy không phải cùng
mình nhưng mà mình sẽ giải thích lại cho
các bạn và để các bạn Nói chung là gần
như là giới thiệu thôi giới thiệu cho
các bạn để thấy được là yoe thực sự nó
là như thế thì nó là gì Và nó hấp dẫn
như thế nào rồi mình đọc của lắm đi
anh không không không phải là học sớm
đâu Thì mình đăng là 8 giờ bắt đầu học
đúng không Thì 7 rưỡi chủ yếu là mình
tâm sự gì đó tâm sự mỏng thì cái gì đó
để mà ngoài qua nói chung ở kiểu để làm
quen con người thân thiện với các bạn
thôi nên là có những bạn nào mà kiểu chỉ
muốn học thôi thì 8 giờ bắt đầu học ngon
vẫn chuẩn như thế thì
Anh
và hôm nay thì mình ông sớm Mình tranh
thủ chia sẻ một chút về để quan điểm về
học vào chơi của mình mình từng nói cái
điều này với sinh viên của mình và
em chỉ cách cài đặt à Ừ
Ừ tí mình sẽ chỉ các bạn về kiểu nói
chung là mình dậy đến đâu mình sẽ chỉ
các bạn là cần cả những cái gì đúng
không các thứ Thì lúc đầu bây giờ mình
học phải quét thì tao mình cài mấy cái
đó chỉ mới là thôi đúng không
Anh ở mình động vào bếp ạ động và
lightness hình như là rất lạ ít lần Bên
mình vẫn đang dùng Windows thì ra là lập
trình viên cái nói linus thì nó
tiện hơn nhiều cái nhưng mà mình quen
dùng Win rồi
thì mình sẽ dạy hết ml một ít sau đó thì
CS một ít rồi ra Speed cũng một ít nữa
Nói chung là kiểu mình không chuyên về
bên giao diện mình dạy các bạn là mình
dùng khái niệm là lập trình chứ không
phải là thiết kế Nên là các bạn mà muốn
chuyên sâu về bên mảnh Còn em thì ra là
cái cái buổi học này cái khóa của ngài
không không đóng góp được gì nhiều nước
cho các bạn vụ đấy mà mình sẽ chỉ dạy
qua về mấy cái hiển thị cơ bản ở bên fan
để mà về sau sang bên lập trình thì các
bạn hiểu kiểu dạng là có thể hiển thị ra
được kết quả thôi
các video vẫn sẽ lưu lại trên kênh này
nên các bạn tôi sẽ có thể theo dõi kênh
này đúng không hiểu rõ mình xin tên này
là được rồi
Em à mình không dậy mày cả chuyên sâu
rồi nghĩa về mạng đâu thế này là toàn bộ
những cái kiến thức của bà hết và bên mẹ
thì không rành như mình sẽ không dậy gửi
ip2 cài đặt chung về hước tinh lắm
Ừ đúng rồi Cái cái lộ trình Cái này thì
tí chắc là tí mình lên hẳn bài à
Ừ ừ trong 7 vị trong cái buổi hôm trước
bài bài văn thông báo mình chiếu để
thiếu nhỉ nó nó mình mình sẽ dạy là à
anh ngủ quên mất
Ừ thôi kia mình sẽ dạng HTML này sau đó
thì CS một ít là rò ra Swift này
ra và
clip sau đó thì đến TP rồi cung là thêm
kết hợp với cả máy kia đó khóa học này
hóa các bạn mình sẽ nhận những điều này
chắc là mình sẽ để cái cái này vào trong
phần mô tả của cái cái danh sách này để
các bạn sẽ hình dung
Ừ ừ đúng rồi video video nào trên
YouTube thường cũng sẽ có một vài ông bà
Bích Lan Thi thoảng mình cũng ăn ít like
- gieo mình là vui
các bạn bạn kia tên lái xe code website
bạn thích thì bạn cứ tâm sự thôi Nếu mà
vì tôi quá Nhìn bóng mình tâm sự cũng
được
ổ khóa này chủ yếu họ Bắc em thì cũng có
một phần đúng đúng là mình sẽ dạy các
bạn chuyên bác em hơn nhưng mà không
phải phía sau cái này tất cả trẻ cơ bản
để các bạn hình dung được một website nó
như thế nào mà mua mình có hôm trước
mình có ghi phần mô tả của cái khó anh
rồi đấy thì các bạn thử đọc qua
cho mình dự tính kênh YouTube này phát
triển như thế nào á
thực tế thì bạn hỏi câu cũng rất lời
đúng nó hay bởi vì bởi vì là phải vậy
tại sao mình không tạo hoặc bột canh
riêng xong rồi tên nó hẳn là cái gì đó
dạy lập trình hãy gì đó Tại sao mình
dùng
kênh cá nhân cũng như là để đổi tên kênh
này thành cái biệt danh của mình rồi thì
mình về sau cũng chắc là cũng sẽ định
nhằm truy mơ khi mở ở đây có thể là khi
mà mình mình đang định hướng là có thể
là khi mở hơn nửa vời nhưng ý nghĩa là
vừa
vừa thỉnh thoảng có mấy cái Vlog tâm sự
rằng ăn nó học chia sẻ cái gì đó đồng
thời là cũng có thể lập trình chứ không
chỉ đơn thuần là dại như thế này mình
mình nghĩ là thế thì có rất nhiều chuyên
mơ chuyển vọng nổi hơn rồi nhưng mà mình
mình không quan trọng điều ấy lắm Mình
có phong cách riêng mà không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi Học xong cái này chắc chắn
các bạn sẽ vẹn cốt phải nói chung là
kiểu gì xong tài khóa học này các bạn sẽ
có được một cái quét sai cơ bản à khi
massage cơ bản ở đây mình sẽ nói qua
luôn với sai cơ bản mình sẽ dậy sẽ là là
một vào web xem tin tức
hay là sẽ là website bán hàng
một cái kiểu 2 kiểu này Tại sao lại tính
tức bán Hà tin tức hình mức độ nào rất
là dễ theo kiểu là chỉ cần việc là
nhìn chị lên bài đã đăng có cựu thứ sau
đó
một bên là quản lý bà đăng một bên đó
xem bài đăng còn còn bán hàng thì nó mức
độ khó hơn một tí nó có cả khách hàng và
có cả quản lý rồi quản lý sản phẩm các
thứ thứ nhưng mà để các bạn hình dung
được bài toán của một website thì phải
web các bạn web bán hàng nó khóa tổng
quan hơn đấy Mình thấy Thu Ca rất nhiều
nơi dạy lập trình cũng thường anh dạy
theo kiểu phong cách kiểu như thế nghĩa
dậy từ mấy cái bài toán thực tế như thế
để mà các bạn dễ hình dung được
Ừ đúng rồi hai cái này quá chỗ mặc định
rồi rất nhiều nói vậy mà
ừ ừ
ổ khóa này thì mình có đăng ấy đó là
mình dự định là sẽ là 23 tháng có bạn
bảo là nhanh Thế nhưng thực tế thì một
buổi này một buổi này là con như là nó
nó chỉ là toàn bộ thì Đức thôi còn các
bạn sẽ phải tự tự thực hành sẽ có người
bạn thân chị ơi mình dậy đến buổi thứ ba
rồi Nhưng bạn ấy vẫn bị xem lại buổi 172
đôi vừa là bạn đấy vẫn chưa được hàng
song Bà vẫn chưa hiểu hết về sẽ đi xem
lại để hiểu thế nên là nói chung là hai
23 tháng mà một tuần chị hai buổi thì
thứ ba mọi thứ bảy đúng không Thì thực
ra là nó không hả này nó không hẳn là
kiểu nhiều nó không hoàn lại đít đâu Nói
chung mà mình sẽ phải cân nhắc chỉnh
chỉnh lại sao cho phù hợp với các bạn
nữa đúng không vân vân Nhưng nói chung
là các bạn vẫn sẽ phải ạ Em tự học khả
năng các các bạn học online mà không có
ai kèm các bạn nên các bạn vẫn phải tự
hợp với tốt Tuy nhiên các bạn có thể
đăng câu hỏi lên để mình hoặc là các bạn
khó trả lời nhưng mà vẫn là tự giác và
chủ yếu rồi mà không học online được giá
luôn nhé ạ
chứ không phải dậy xong khóa này có cô
trách gì đâu mà trong chính quá này sẽ
là forex rồi đấy thì khi mà đến môn P và
máy Ware thì mình sẽ đưa đề tài luôn và
các bạn sẽ thử tự chọn đề tài sau đó thì
mình sẽ dạy mình sẽ dạy theo cái đề tài
đấy để như mình vừa nói là mình sẽ có 2
đề tài nó là tin tức và bán hàng đấy các
bạn sẽ phải dậy thiện sẽ phải tự chọn đề
tài và làm cả hai có thể có thể làm cả
hai đứa này cũng được
em chưa học SQL Thực ra vào bênh xem
cũng được vì hôm nay nó mấy buổi này vẫn
là độc lập nhưng mình khuyên là các bạn
cũng nên học cho các bạn dầm sắm xong
kiểu kiểu thế để khi mà mình nghỉ sang
tiếp p kèm theo máy quê out thì thì mình
sẽ không dại lại Excel cơ bản mấy nữa mà
các bạn sẽ phải tự hiểu sẵn rồi
bởi vì bây giờ mà cứ giảng đi giảng lại
thì những cái bạn theo từ buổi đầu rồi
các bạn ấy nghe buồn ngủ rồi chán
ờ ờ bỏ học cấp 3 bị dẫn hơn vào ngày nào
à Mình quen vẫn rất nhiều người cũng
kiểu dạng mà bỏ học các thứ thứ
cho đến bây giờ vẫn giòn không sao Mình
không quan trọng với việc là học tập lắm
rồi đi học tập của mình bết bát lắm
Ừ Ok có vẻ lạ là thứ năm mình không dậy
à Thế năm thì ra bạn chắc là chưa xem
cho bảo mình Thứ năm thì mình sẽ bây giờ
mình sẽ dậy ép keo chuyên sâu mình sẽ
tách hẳn ra một khóa riêng và hòa Apache
sâu để mà cho bạn nào mà ba nha theo
ngành Công nghệ thông tin này bạn đấy
tiểu bang học dở FeO Bạn ấy thích
ashworth chẳng hạn thì bạn về hoặc các
bạn có nhiều bài tập ở trường vân vân
vân đấy thì bạn bé mà thực tế
tôi khuyên mấy ông một câu chân thành
này đó là
nếu mà Mấy ông đang theo mày có mẹ công
ty Ý bé ông nghĩ rằng em không quan
trọng là một trong những cái sai này cái
thứ hai là nếu mà ông đã theo ngành công
nghệ tin để miền Bắc em mà Mấy ông
anh không không biết về FA lắm thì có
khi phải treo máy buổi SV trên sau đấy
với thực tế nghỉ lúc mà mình mình đi làm
vậy với mấy anh có cả anh Mạnh Tuấn nhé
Để bê đang nói xấu hiệu trưởng luôn thì
ở mấy cái kiến thức mà mình sắp dạy và
bồi Thứ 5 này nè vào cái khóa Thứ 5 này
mấy người không phải biết luôn không hề
biết luôn không phải biết Nó tồn tại
luôn đi chứ không
Bởi vì nó chứa sau mà mấy người đấy sẽ
biết chỉ biết đúng kiểu cơ bản rồi thành
ra là đông đi nhiên là thực tế thì
họ năn biết chỉ cần biết các bạn mà họ
vẫn làm được việc họ vẫn họ vẫn thậm chí
họ vẫn lên liền Suneo và ballet nằm ít
họ không cần phải chuyên bên Fe FeO thực
tế là có người khác đã Nghiện cũng có
nghe họ không cần ở chuyên như ý mình là
ở họ không biết được để ép em nó thể
2000 thế
đi chuyến sau nhé không mình sẽ không
dùng từ và nâng cao mà là chuyên sâu
nâng cao là một kịch kẻ khác mình sẽ cân
nhắc mình dậy Còn chuyên sau ở đây chỉ
những cái khá nhiễm khác của esquare
thôi chính mình để cái đường link được
ra các bạn biết các bạn tra nhìn thấy
nhiều đường link này rồi
mình sẽ để lại bình minh nữa à
sau khi các bạn bấm vào đường link này
các bạn sẽ thấy ra cái đấy mình bấm thử
các bạn xem
khi Apple chuyên sâu chính là những cái
này à
ở đầu tiên thì khóa cơ bản của mình đã
chạy qua có lệnh mẫu cơ bản và con trên
rồi nho hoàn toàn bộ những cái bên này
những cái tát này
Đấy là những cái mình chưa dậy và bên fg
trên sau mình sẽ dậy thì thì nói chung
là để cho các bạn
cuối buổi mình cho là sẽ có câu hỏi khi
mình nát này có bạn trả lời hết được tất
cả đúng này thì các bạn muốn thực sự
hiểu Nó thể sâu và nó hay bị như nào ông
nào mà có hương thú một tí về ép với
nhau đấy Mà học cái buổi FM trên sông
này mình khẳng định luôn các bạn sẽ yêu
Apple hơn ngôn ngữ lập trình với học lấy
xăm tôi thích dậy em queo tục mê nó cực
kỳ nghe mình nói như đa cấp lại dỗi xin
lỗi à
ừ ừ
xe nâng cao nâng cao là kiểu là những
cái câu ở những cái câu thực tế Nói
thẳng luôn thực tế là s line nâng cao
chính là những cái câu c nách này nhưng
mà nó tốc độ mức độ khó mà nó rất phức
tạp đó là câu c lách mầm có selec rồi
salad cho dùng các thứ xong rồi Sắp
Paris đó thử và rất là sau thì đấy mới
là nâng cao
cô còn chuyến sau thì sẽ chỉ là những
cái khái niệm rất nhiều khái niệm mới ở
trong Excel thôi bộ phim
anh không mình dạy miễn phí Mình làm từ
trước nay thở ra mà cũng chọn có người
bảo mình mình tốn nhiều thời gian thế
xong một tuần mà mình không thu lại cái
gì à Thì mình còn nói đùa à ơi thì tôi
thu lại được người theo dõi tôi thu lại
được sự nổi tiếng
kiểu thế Nhưng thực sự đúng với Trần Phú
lại cái gì thì với quan điểm của nhiều
người điển hình ứng dụng cho cơ lại
không làm gì đó Bạn giỏi mà miễn phí ạ
thì bé mình đi ngược về cái quan điểm
đấy mình mình không bận tâm về vật chất
lắm thành ra là kiểu Ý
ở mình khó khó ăn thì da mình không muốn
làm giàu lắng trợ dễ
Ừ đúng rồi Chuyên sau là nhiều khái niệm
còn nâng cao mới phức tạp cho nhà đất
chú ý
ờ ờ
khi tải hình khóa học này sẽ dạy các bạn
về tự code web bán hàng này đúng không
tích hợp cổng thanh toán thì ra mà nó
lại dễ bởi vì mấy hàng này nó có sẵn cắt
số thử rồi các bạn chỉ ôm cốt mà về là
thích hợp được
Anh
bắt em phức tạp lắm hả anh cái này chắc
là phải phải tự hỏi về việc là bạn thấy
lương của lập trình viên bác em nói
chung là lương của ông nào càng cao
chứng tỏ là nó càng phức tạp càng ít
người ở trong ngành đấy thì mới có lượng
mức lương hấp dẫn như thế đấy nó sẽ trả
lời đấy
cho mình không có khái niệm Donut là nằm
đâu nhưng mà chắc là vì sao mình sẽ phải
nhờ các bạn một cái một cái mình đã nghĩ
việc đẩy rồi cho về sau mình sẽ nhờ các
bạn một cái
em vừa mang tính cá nhân nhậu vừa mang
tính cấp đồng
Cái này thì mình xin phép nói sau A
30 bình mình sẽ công nhận là nó sẽ mức
độ khó và phức tạp đấy nó không đơn giản
đâu những cái gì mình khó thì mình sẽ
không lừa sinh viên dùng như thầy mình
sẽ nói đó là khó thì sẽ
anh có thể nhìn lại cố nói là dễ để cho
sinh viên mình chịu học không Mình không
như thế được khó thì bị sẽ nói là khó dễ
thì mình sẽ nó là dễ ờ
em kêu gọi quyên góp và miền Trung
10 sự thật thì À cái này con điểm thôi
cái video này không được quay quay lại
cho không biết mấy ông có nên làm tốt
không Nhưng cái này là con đỉa đó là
mình
mình thì mình thường ấy không ủng hộ mấy
cái từ thiện mình không Mình không mình
không đi làm từ thiện thôi nhưng mà mình
không có vấn đề gì về vấn đề đấy cả
những ý mình và mình
cảm thấy mấy cái từ thiện hàng năm nay
có lỡ thứ mà mình không giải quyết được
cái cái gốc rễ của nó hoặc giống như là
bây giờ ông học công nghệ thông tin rồi
Không sợ thì
Ừ ông phải áp dụng công nghệ vào để giải
quyết cho họ cái vướng cái cái gì đó
trong cuộc sống của họ chứ không thể cứ
Năm nào cũng đi quyên góp tiền mà họ sẽ
ổn được cả gì thực sự thực sự thì năm
sau nó lại thế mạnh trôi nhà cửa rồi các
thứ thứ mình thấy thực sự thì cái đề nó
không giải quyết được mấu chốt vấn đề
Ừ nó cần phải áp dụng rất nhiều cái để
mà khiến thay đổi nó chấm dứt hẳn đi nói
chung và mình mấy chị đã nói thế nhưng
thật ra là bây giờ cũng không biết làm
những cái gì đúng không Nhưng thực sự
thì mình nghĩ là mình phải giữ giải
quyết gốc rễ vấn đề hơn là kiểu mình cứ
đi
Ừ năm nào đi từ thiện trăm tỷ 2.000 tỷ
là đến như mình không nói việc là bây
giờ các bạn không nên từ thiện nữa hả
Nói thế thì trẻ đúng không
anh nói chung mà vẫn phải cứu họ lúc này
nhưng mà ý mình nhà
mình thì không có tiền trả nợ hay mình
không Mình không có thời gian để mạ bản
thân mình cũng phải tự xoay xở cho mình
Vân Vân không thể rút họp liên tục được
nhưng mà nếu mình đã có tâm thì thực ra
là mình không Chị gửi tiền cho họ là
xong thì ra không như thế Mình mình có
tâm thì Được dự mình phải thay đổi khiến
cho cuộc đời họ không bao giờ như thế
nữa thì nó ổn hơn Đúng là cái vấn đề này
phá nhạy cảm nhưng mà vì ý mình là như
thế Mình nghĩ là vì sao mình sẽ
Ờ Ờ
mình sẽ giúp giúp họ mình bằng những
cách mà mình giỏi hơn là chị vận động
quyên góp tiền để thực sự thì
anh trai cả khái niệm về từ từ thiện hay
là đóng góp cái gì đó nhiều lúc quan
điểm của mình nó giống như là kiểu
mình mình gửi tiền cho họ để em lương
tâm mình thanh thản chứng thực sự là
mình còn không không biết được là họ sẽ
như thế nào để con điểm của mình về từ
thiện của nhiều người bây giờ
nhiều người từ từ thiện theo đúng Khánh
hiểm đây họ không quan tâm Thực sự là
người kia nó sẽ như thế nào ạ
10 cái cần câu ở đây là một phần thôi
Đang bảo nó ra họ gặp nhiều khó khăn như
thế nhỉ nói chung phải có nhiều về Rạch
Giỏi quá ta dạy bài toán giải quyết khác
chứ không phải mỗi thế
thôi Bây giờ nó hơi đặc đề mất rồi Mình
chia xét chia sẻ một chút về cái
quan điểm học và chơi này trước khi vào
buổi buổi học của hôm nay đúng không
ế quá nên học cả văn và bác Đúng rồi bạn
quá này sẽ học cả văn cả bác mình có
mình có đề cập cho mình lỡ cam sẽ kém
tuổi mình có đề cập tới sẽ học một tí
khoan tôi không phải chuyện được con nhé
à
ờ ờ
có những buổi học tiếp theo mà những
buổi học tiếp theo của mình thì sẽ học
chắc là nói thế Mình vẫn sẽ phải lên bà
vậy có nhiều bạn quan tâm Kiều dạng sẽ
học những Bùi gì tiếp theo nhỉ cây mình
sẽ lên Lên lịch trình cho các bạn về mấy
cái vụ này nhá đi
à à
a web và Mobile sao anh đáng ra cái nào
khó hơn
bị chế độ rung Mobile nên mình không
không dám khẳng định gì ở đây cả
Anh bắt em mình sẽ học HTML và để trong
những mạng với lại được
HTML + CF +
ra 3 clip + dp + MF AF và mình sẽ học có
khả năng tiêu chuẩn
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi Học xong khóa này mình mình
sẽ làm được một website cơ bản
thì mình sẽ bắt buộc phải làm được một
cái sản phẩm với sai cơ bản được chưa và
Ê bà khóa sau cái hóa sau sẽ làm Lập
trình là nâng cao không phải nâng cao
nhưng mà nói chung là nó chắc là nó sẽ
có phải cơ bản nữa mình sẽ dạy các bạn
về phía sau thì mình sẽ dạy về lauriel
cộng vẫn là cộng mai que Thôi để làm một
cái bài toán xử lý bài toán thực tế
và hoàn toàn là cái khóa sau đấy cũng
lần này mình không dùng từ chuyên sâu
được bởi vì nó hẳn nâng cao rồi bắt buộc
phải phải Lâm trình lên hoàn toàn để mà
các bạn đi được tập được học xong việc
khóa quá
khóa sau đúng không là lập trình nâng
cao
và các bạn hoàn toàn phải đi thực tập
được
ở thị trường Mỹ sẽ không dùng từ chuyên
sâu được bởi vì chính sâu là các bạn hãy
sâu hơn mày TP Thực ra học xong cái t cơ
bản là quá đủ rồi mà empower cơ bản đã
quá đủ các bạn không cần học chuyên sâu
nữa các bạn phải nâng hàng cao lên nghĩa
là các bạn phải biết ngồi cày level 1
Facebook này chẳng lại các bạn áp dụng
một cái phương thuốc kết hợp với cái éo
cơ bản asun này cũng là nâng cao trong
mà còn là cơ bản nữa đó sau đó thì để xử
lý một bài toán thực tế để các bạn
anh hiểu được một website chuẩn là một
web sang xúc tạp wi-fi kiểu kiểu dạng là
quản lý người dùng hay là một cái gì đó
kiểu vĩ mô một tí phải dùng tư thế thì
mới đi thực tập được
cái hóa sau thì mình chắc là cũng trẻ 22
tháng 2 3 tháng thôi Bởi vì thôi mình
dậy sinh viên mình chỉ cần đấy đấy thì
nghĩa là nghe có vẻ hấp dẫn đúng không
học hết quá Này 23 tháng mới cho hành 3
tháng nhưng không sau đó thì các bạn lại
học tiếp hóa sau của ba hàng nữa đi
Chẳng hạn nửa năm nữa là các bạn đi thực
tập được nghe Món này ngon
Ừ nhưng mà thực tế thì nó đúng thế Đúng
là thế luôn ý nhé bởi vì mình dạy cho
sinh viên ở trường mình đúng như thế mặt
đúng chỉ sau nửa năm là các bạn ấy đi
tập này ạ
cho nên là mình mình bảo của mình áp
dụng đúng cái cái mình đã dậy ở trên
trường của mình là trường nghề đào tạo
nề mà mặc áp dụng về thế nên là các bạn
sẽ thấy nó rất là hiệu quả
thì nó sẽ không bị nhàm chán khô khan
thế nhưng để các bạn thực sự là dọn thì
được nghe các bạn khả năng tự học cũng
phải rất ổn và các bạn phải tự giác nữa
tự giác để mà để mà làm Mình dẫn đến đâu
rồi Các bạn cũng phải bắt được 5 năm sáu
phần lên đấy và các bạn vẫn sẽ phải tự
ôn lại tự làm sản phẩm riêng cho mình
Sau đó một này các bạn phải làm một An
sau khóa này các bạn phải làm một cái
trang web rồi mong một loại tin tức hay
bán hàng đúng không hạn chế làm cả hai
Ngoan quá sau đó tiếp theo thì cái khóa
này các bạn lại phải làm một trang web
nữa liên quan đến quản lý hay cái gì đó
mình sẽ dạy các bạn về quản lý sinh viên
hoặc là một trang web Đặt vé xem phim mà
hai cái gì đấy nói chung cái này thì
mình sẽ cân nhắc bởi vì mình không thể
dạy các bạn tất cả tất cả được nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà các bạn học xong cái này thì
các bạn hoàn toàn thể đi thực tập được
Ê bà Thậm chí có thể để
đấy thì mình nghĩ là
cho các bạn nếu mà có bạn ơi bảo là
thích ra vâng ạ Ở đây bài toán ngôn ngữ
ngôn ngữ lập trình Nó chỉ là một cái yếu
tố để mà các bạn làm ra một sản phẩm đó
Mà nó có bạn dùng ngôn ngữ lập trình nào
được nhưng mà mình đang cố dậy các bạn
về một cái mà nó dễ học nó kiểu cũng
đang tuyển dụng cũng cao vân vân
đề thi ạ Các bạn có thể cứ theo nó này
đã rồi có bạn Vì sao thích cái ngôn ngữ
lập trình nào vân vân vân thì có bạn
hoàn toàn có về
Em học cái đấy mà đúng không
Mà công nhận hôm nay đông phết I khoa
học trên trường thì nó bị lý thuyết Hàn
lâm quá nằm các bạn Thiện làm và các bạn
thấy kiểu nó bị mâm lum
cái này mình đã từng nói rồi học lập
trình này nó giống như kiểu các bạn bước
vào trong một cái xương ngủ vậy
Ừ chị à
Ừ thì các thầy cô là người mà kiểu cầm
cái đen người ta nhìn được đường người
ta thuộc đường người ta chỉ lỗi các bạn
vượt qua cái sương mù đấy thì ông nào mà
kiểu tin tưởng thầy cô thì bán cho thầy
cô đến cùng để dần dần ông nào là thì
ông ấy dậm chân tại chỗ mới bỏ đúng
không đi
Ừ Ok có vẻ không mấy đúng phết mình
không thể để trải giáo án được nữa không
ạ
Cho mình xin phép là thứ nhất là câu này
sẽ là thứ năm mình trả lời này
câu này thì khối buổi này mình sẽ chỉ
qua các bạn Ui ux là gì này nó sẽ là một
bài rất hay về vui which mình chia sẻ về
quan điểm học qua chơi
23 phút thôi mình sẽ cách 23 phút rồi
thì à
Ừ quan điểm của mình ấy là
Ờ Ờ
mình là một thằng Thực ra là tôi rất
nhiều Mình tâm hỏi cái vụ là mình trốn
học đi nét cũng như là mình trốn cả đi
thi học sinh giỏi để đi nét thấy rõ ra
đi thi học sinh giỏi ấp lương hơn ennis
vui hơn mà có tội gì đấy à
Ừ Thì
Ừ mình
đậu xanh chào mang
ừ ừ
Ừ
tự nhiên hiệu trưởng vào lại nghe nhất
thành vụn ép rồi ngôi sao
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Ừ nhưng mà thực tế là mình mình họ cũng
sẽ ra học giống như hôm nay có bạn bảo
với mình đó là em học trên trường thì em
chán vân vân quan điểm của mình khi học
sinh trường ấy đó là mình sẽ không bao
giờ ngủ ở trên trường mình không bao giờ
chơi ở trên trường mình có thể nói
chuyện với bạn bè rồi thì rõ ràng là ở
nhà làm gì có ai nói chuyện nên lợn lên
trường thì gặp bạn bè thì nhưng nói
chuyện mình là một thằng nói nhiều mà à
Ừ nhưng mà mình sẽ không chơi game trong
lớp hay là ngủ nè Làm việc riêng trong
lớp khi học thì mình sẽ chỉ học thầy của
mình từng là một người thầy không biết
là người thầy tốt hay là người tệ Theo
mình là tốt nhiều người sẽ không thích
điều đó Tại sao thầy ra bài tập xong
thấy mất hút luôn
thấy đúng kiểu để cho các bạn tự học
tinh thần tự học các bạn với rất cao thờ
37 Nhưng mà nhiều âm gì rồi không làm
bài Ông mở máy ra Chơi game luôn để
chiều mình là trường nghề Ai có cái máy
tính của ai cũng được phát hành máy tính
ngay trước mặt để có thể lên mạng để mà
ngồi làm ngồi học nhưng mà Mấy ông ấy
toàn ngồi lướt face nữa là Tải game về
chơi
thì mình ngồi làm hết được đổi mới tập
đấy mình ngồi nghĩ ra câu sao nghị nghĩ
là những cái đề khác mình vừa làm mình
không phải ngủ đâu Xong những câu Sao
mày không giải được thì mình cố tìm bằng
được thầy mình để mình hỏi thầy mình thì
cũng áp lực lắm thầy đang ngồi hút thuốc
hoặc ngồi đá pass Tự nhiên thấy thằng
học sinh cư
anh cứ lao vào rồi rồi hỏi hỏi hỏi I
ở đây thì cứ mà thầy vẫn sẽ trả lời này
các thứ thì quan điểm của mình ở thế
Mình đóng tiền mà mình đến đấy để mình
rút cạn cái tiền mình đã nóng để học
được cái gì đó chứ không phải là mình
tải cũ tải game về để mà ngồi chơi bởi
vì tôi đấy tôi học là 100.000 à Ba triệu
một tháng
ý nghĩa là 100.000 11 ngày mà chính xác
là một buổi một buổi đấy chị có bốn
tiếng nữa là một tiếng là 25.000
25.000 khâu ông ngồi chơi cái máy cùi
bắp lấy tôi Giang quán net ăn mì uống
Sting còn chẳng nhớ đến cái ra đấy Bùi
cả đít luôn
Thế nên là một cái sẽ không bao giờ tốn
tiền thì em ngồi chơi game mà lấy cả
nghe mày ngu si vãi chưởng thà bỏ buổi
học đấy gì Đi net còn hơn
đúng không ạ Ừ
ông ông công thức tính đi Đúng không ông
thích bỏ ra nắm lấy tiền mỗi ngày để một
tiếng Hà Nội để mà để mà ngồi cố cái
chơi máy đều đấy Xong rồi mấy ông chủ
béo kia thì sướng nhỉ đừng ngồi chơi
aram ở trong lớp học là mấy sướng
Ừ thì mấy ông thấy quan điểm sai đúng
không học Cho Ba học tôi về nhà tôi
không vừa học tôi chỉ đi nét thôi nhưng
mà nhưng mà khi mà đi học tôi chỉ học
thôi à
à à
anh đúng không Con điểm mình rất rõ ràng
việc học mà chơi như thế
Ê mấy ông bao giờ có đang nghĩ lại về
bản thân mình đã phí phạm tiền nhau cho
không đúng không em đều nghĩ lại đi ừ
[âm nhạc]
Anh Không Nghỉ Nghỉ tiết đó Cái gì mấy
ông nghị nghỉ học luôn được bởi vì thời
Ca Trường tôi chứng nghề nên cái bằng
cấp của trường tôi gần như không giá trị
luôn tôi nói thế hơi phụ ga tôi hình như
tôi mình sẽ lấy băng người chưa tốt
nghiệp rồi nhưng tôi có lấy bằng đâu có
gì ai chẳng ai hỏi tôi bằng tất cả bằng
vậy cũng chẳng có giá trị gì cả à
ở nhà thôi mà thôi đi rahma hơi quá rồi
mình hôm nay mình xin phép giận bảo là
dậy à đây lập trình website cơ bản
anh làm quen được không đấy Sau đó thì à
ở đầu tiên trả lời câu hỏi của mỗi hai
câu đúng không ạ
a
tiếp theo làm quen vừa web và cuối cùng
là chia sẻ kinh nghiệm đúng không bộc lộ
hôm nay em như thế thì đầu tiên mà Thì
quét sai ấy Website là gì thì
ở
mình thường hay lấy ví dụ này cho sinh
viên
Ừ cái này là một cái sai đúng không
Không thấy rõ ràng mà đây là một website
mà câu
không thường hay thấy Facebook nữa là
mỗi file rất nhiều Nói chung là các bạn
sẽ nhận ra là website Mình tiếp xúc rất
nhiều rồi youtube này là một cái sai
đúng không Các bạn cứ dùng bằng trình
duyệt như thế này để truy cập vào thì nó
có thể tính là một website rồi đừng chưa
khi bé bắt đầu buổi học tại tập trung
tập trung vào vấn đề này To tiếng lên bé
thích gần hơn nữa
alo thì chưa to quá alo
ờ thì
ở các các ông thấy rõ ràng là đây là một
website đúng không Nhưng mà để mà làm đã
được website này nếu không phải là ngồi
kiểu ngồi Chỉnh sửa giao diện Ngồi ngồi
kiểu vẽ ra từng cái chữ Dân Trí hay các
thứ mấy ông thấy tất cả Đây rõ ràng chữ
video này khác Triệu Dân Trí này chữ
video này phát chữ Cô vip này xong rồi
có chữ bé chữ to đây đúng không Thì
một bể
ừ ừ
How to quá xin lỗi nhé Thì để làm được
website như này bản chất là mình sẽ lập
trình ra nó thì mình các bạn để xem được
cốt của mỗi sai thì các bạn ấn concho
Xem đấy đấy Nó xảy ra hết đây đây chỉ nó
cố của website nhiều âm thì biết cái chỗ
này Rồi thì chưa nhưng không biết rồi
mình xin phép bây giờ mình không nhìn
vào chat nữa nhé không mình mất tập
trung lắm mình không thể làm được không
bị dậy được liên tục
ờ ờ
Ừ thì bây giờ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mấy ông
về cái việc em làm ta được website đương
nhiên là không đẹp được như thế này nếu
với lại chê trang Dân Trí xấu nhưng mà
về cơ bản thì nó đẹp khi mà ông Khi mà
mì ông gửi sang học lâm sẽ thấy để làm
chả ngày khó vãi
Okay đây chưa Ngồi bắt đầu vào học nha
ở đây mình xin phép bởi vì nó làm
website thì nên là sao mình
A và mình sẽ học hôm nay mình sẽ cái đầu
tiên mình học sẽ chị nghe hát tiền bao
lâu nữa mình tạm mà
Ừ có gì phải
tắt hết Đố mày đi à
Chúng tôi có một thư mục sẵn rồi kỹ sư
school này Đấy thư mục HTML này Đầu tiên
thì tôi sẽ lưu một cái như một cái file
phải đi
Ừ mai này sẽ tên là để mô chắng HTML Bởi
vì tôi dậy không HTML thì nên là tôi sẽ
phải có đuôi là trắng hmg được chưa có
mấy ông thì sẽ thấy luôn nó lấy biểu
tượng hình Chrome mà Đây đúng không Và
khi tôi mở nó lên thì nó sẽ ra một cái
trang trắng tinh như này đúng không
ạ Bây giờ tôi cần hiển thị ra mấy cái
dòng chữ ví dụ là xin chào các bạn chẳng
hạn hoặc Hero World thường được dậy
World đúng không đấy thì tôi sẽ phải sửa
lại cái file này sửa lại cái file này để
hiển thị ra được cái này là xin chào Cái
gì đó khi sửa file này như thế nào
thường là thực tế các bạn sửa bằng word
hay bằng Notepad hay bằng bất kì cái gì
cũng được nhưng mà nó không được sĩ nó
lắm Tại sao để mình thử nhé mình sẽ sửa
nó bằng nút Paddy
các bạn mình sẽ mở Notepad open
à à
ở
đại mở nó bằng pass đây này
Em nói như này
các
phím tắt của tôi vừa dùng để mà hiển thị
hay Cửa sổ thì ông có thể dùng Windows
Windows rồi mũi tên mà chọn thằng này
sang bên trái rồi chọn cái này sang bên
phải nhé ạ
cho
hai thằng nó sẽ ở cạnh nhau một cách cân
xứng rất ngon lắm
ừ ừ
anh idol mình là xưởng lưu mình gõ chữ
Hello em ạ Mình ăn lưu lại nhé Cho tả
lại sang bên này nó sẽ ra chữ Hello Thế
xong là ngon đó Thi thống kê ông sẽ thấy
à Đây là cần đưa là làm xong rồi một cái
sai rồi
nhưng mà hpl nó không chỉ đơn giản thế
này bây giờ giả sử là các bạn muốn
Em muốn làm cho chữ nó to lên đúng không
địa chỉ Mình sẽ có những bộ thẻ riêng
cho nó để cho nó chữ nó sẽ kiểu to lên
hèn là màu mè hơn với Vân Vân Vân à
xe tải thì mình sẽ khái niệm là thể H1
như này mà đóng thẻ một như thế này
ừ ừ
Ừ thì các bạn thấy Để ý kỹ ở đây nhá
cách để mà ghi HTML nó sẽ là có mở thẻ
như này sau đó đi tên của thẻ
ở đó sau đó đi ở bên trong này sẽ chứa
dạy chưa Cái cái chữ như thế này vào
cung là bóng thẻ thì thêm cái súp chéo
ngang nữa mà tên hẹ xắt nữa bơ mình sẽ
trả lại trang này đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy
nó sẽ sự khác biệt đúng không một hàng
thì mình em tôi thong dong nhá một thằng
thì nó chữ như ngày 1 tháng chịu như này
đúng không Bởi vì tha ngày thì nó sẽ
dùng cái thẻ này không có thể nào cả
đúng không Nhưng bản chất nhé tia hoài
không nằm trong thẻ nào cả thì hành
trình duyệt hoặc vẫn sẽ để tự mặc định
mặc định cho nó sẽ là tê như thế này
được chưa nó không tập trung vào mấy ông
chung nào đậu xanh có mang Đông tôi
không quản lý mấy ông Hợp
Ừ
cái thịt cái thẻ này nó là thật đầu tiên
này thể hát này nó sẽ là viết tắt của
heping và thể tiêu đề chưa và một này
thể hiện nó là cỡ to nhất một là to nhất
mình cho và mới ông sẽ thắc mắc là thế
Số nào là số bé nhất thì số 6 sẽ số bé
nhất được chưa số 6 nó còn bé hơn cả bé
hơn cả thể cây này có mình cho cho miếng
xem ạ ạ
chỉ số càng to thì ra loại càng bé
Ừ
nhưng mà nó vẫn sẽ in đậm đúng không Các
bạn thấy nó vẫn sẽ in đậm tiền nó bé hơn
nhưng mà nó vỡ tiêu đề này vẫn nó vẫn sẽ
được in đậm gì cả
Còn hệ p này thì mấy ông thấy à thể tê
này so với việc không có thể p thì như
tôi đã nói thì
à à Hình như tôi đã nói thì mặc định sự
mặc định nếu mà Mấy ông không để nó
trong thẻ Vì nó vẫn sẽ là thực hiểu là
nằm trong thiệp p thì chưa và thể p này
nó cái tắt của gì nó là pha grab tức là
thể văn bản
à Tôi đang thi thoảng nói cho mấy ông
mày cái việc viết tắt để cho nó ngầu
thật ra mình không cần nhớ điều đấy ra
nó vẫn được không sao cả
Nhưng mà Mấy ông mà có thắc mắc gì chị
đấy tôi thể hiện tiếng Anh ấy ông ấy ý
anh nói chung à Cái này đã gần như là
ý kiến thức cơ bản của htl rồi
ở lại gần đưa xong 11 rồi nhai bất ngờ
không ạ ý
kiến thức cơ bản của HTML nó là gì nọ nó
bản chất nó chỉ là mờ thẻ tên cụ thể và
bắn thẻ sau đó thì cái cái ở giữa này
làm nội dung của thẻ thì chưa Sau đó thì
ở đây lại là đóng thẻ như này nó sau đó
em bé Ông thấy thức khtn còn rất là dễ
ừ ừ
Ừ
nhưng mà bây giờ Xanh bài toán thêm một
tí kiến thức nữa đi xem nào đúng không
Cái này có dễ quá bây giờ xử Hello như
này
dưới lạnh Hero nghe nhé thôi Enter một
đống như này cho mày ông nhé
ô tô tại cha mày
đi thi I
Ừ thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là ở đây rõ ràng
là tôi em tôi rất nhiều Hòa Thuận chí là
tôi thay enter bằng rất nhiều dấu cách
như này
khi mà sang bên này thì nó vẫn chỉ tính
bằng một dấu cách thôi đúng không chỉ
Ừ cái Tại sao lại như thế bởi vì toàn bộ
cái hiển thị ở trên trình duyệt nó phải
theo quy tắc của htl rồi chưa thì mấy
ông muốn để cho muốn để mà muốn nó thành
thành kiểu đồ xuống dòng hết đúng không
Thì nó sẽ có thể riêng mà nó là thẻ
balogh thẻ Paulo Tức là cái tắt của
liveplex cho dù rõ ràng để sự Jack rồi
nhưng mà nó viết tắt của like cho ra mắt
dòng vì chưa ạ
Ừ thì cấm các bạn sẽ thấy nó xuống dòng
và đương nhiên là càng nhiều PR thì nó
sẽ xuống càng nhiều lắm đúng không là xử
lý ngay Giả sử đây là một động PR đúng
không ạ Bây giờ Bây giờ về rồi nha anh
xuống rất nhiều lắm đúng không ạ
A và thực tế là có bạn nghỉ sẽ từng xong
mắt là em đã từng gặp PR theo kiểu loại
như thế này hoặc thậm chí là như thế này
hoặc là không có cái dấu gì cả Ở trong
cái thẻ thì nó vẫn như nhau được chưa Nó
vẫn như nhau
thì ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy là thể bây giờ
này nó là một thể đặc biệt
Ý đặc biệt bởi vì rõ ràng vừa nãy mình
để trẻ H1 xong nó thì nội dung ở bên
trong như thế này theo này chẳng hiểu
ngay
Hello heo thi
Ừ thì các bạn sẽ thấy ra à thẻ này là
thể bình thường HM là bình thường tất cả
tên hè này Nội dung ở giữa này và có
đóng thẻ con thể bé đồ thì các bạn thấy
là nó nó là thể đặc biệt theo kiểu nó
không có nội dung và vui đó và nó cũng
không cần thể đóng Nó đôi khi nhiều
người còn bảo nó là cái này đóng luôn
thì chưa ạ
Ừ Thì
à À
đây Nói chung nào đây là vừa rồi biết
qua bình những cái sẽ được chưa tiếp
theo là những cách cách để mà các bạn
ghi chuẩn một cái tài liệu HD pro được
không tiếp
a bit
ở đầu tiên thì các bạn không nên dùng
bằng nó pass Chắc chắn rồi Không không
ai làm như kiểu như này bạn sẽ dùng cái
gì mình thì mình dùng cái miễn phí đó là
mình sẽ dùng một cái gọi là sắp
litek cái này này mà miễn phí cho rồi là
mình lại từng mất tiền nó nó hơi đau
nhưng tôi mất 80 đô nó lời khuyên là
công không burn Quyên có khá không lên
gọi nhé
Để ủng hộ
có ai đó bằng bằng một nút ver sau đó
thì chẳng nhận ra ở trong trong ví của
ông hợi bang hơi nhiều tiền
Ừ tôi cứ tưởng nó tắm đô tôi đọc nhiều
bị tắm đô tôi bấm nút kiểu đôi nét cùng
ngộ cùng mua sử cái bản miễn phí 8 video
ạ
anh không thể không ạ
ừ ừ
Ê mấy ông dùng bất kì gái phần mềm gì
thì kệ đi nhá Tôi tôi dậy cho mấy ông
dùng phần mềm này có lý do cả Tại sao
bởi vì à
chị đã tím thỉnh thoảng nó cứ Bye bye
bye bye
ừ ừ
à à
anh
đọc Quay lại cái này nhá ở đây đây một
cái mẹo nữa Thực là thỉnh thoảng tôi
chia sẻ mẹo trong mấy ông liên tục đó là
Ừ tôi thấy ý tôi từng vào máy tính của
rất nhiều không bằng mấy ông để cái cup
set này để mặc định Nếu không bao giờ ẩn
ghim một cái thư mục nào đó rõ ràng là
mấy ông có thể ấn chút phải đây rồi
pinto Quick access này để mà về sau mình
bấm vào đây nó nhanh hơn nhưng không Nếu
không để hưởng tất cả đều là mặc định
destop hơi mấy cái download ở trên này
thường nếu không mưa dùng cái pin to
access thật là kiểu Tôi thấy em mấy ông
sử dụng máy tính kiểu
đi chậm trứng khủng
ở đây Nói chung là quay lại bài nào tạm
tơ mà Đấy bây giờ Giả sử một tài liệu
HTML chuẩn thì nó sẽ gồm những cái gì
thực tế là tôi cũng không bao nhớ hết
được
để cải cách cú pháp ghi một tài liệu đầy
đủ của một tài liệu chuẩn tại sao cụ thể
rõ ràng cái Sắp ai-tek này nó gợi ý cho
tôi đều đấy thử họ nhé HTML xong một cái
Tab ra một cái nó sẽ như này
thấy audio nhiều ông sẽ thấy cậu ấy Cái
này ngầu vãi thì
đề thi
ở tạm thu Trung Tặng cho Trung à
cái cái tài liệu HD vừa chuẩn nó sẽ là
như thế này
ở đầu tiên thì nó sẽ có dòng đầu tiên đã
khai báo phiên bản của htl Đây là cách
khai báo phiên phiên bản của html5
Ừ cái á cái htm5 là HTML mới nhất bệnh
Hiện tại thì chưa những cái htg phiên
bản cũ hơn mà nó khai báo kiểu khác Tại
sao phải khai báo phiên bản HTML bởi vì
cái cảnh Tôi từng nói Tôi nói rồi đó là
cái file HTM này của các ông sẽ chạy
bằng trình duyệt này đúng không ra xử là
cái Trinh dược bẫy dụ Giả sử ie ạ nó
không hỗ trợ hết tl5 chẳng hạn thì nó sẽ
hiển thị lỗi là một cũng như là giờ sự
là gì
Ừ ông ngoại dùng trên mạng hai tầng lầu
cũ hơn thì ông phải khai báo cho trình
duyệt là tao dùng cái cũ hơn chứ nó
không thể hiểu được là ông đang dùng cái
phiên bản nào mỗi mỗi phiên bản thì nó
sẽ có thẻ khác nhau về chưa
ừ ừ
Ừ tôi tiếp theo là các thẻ đề tài liệu
HTML nó là nó mịn chuẩn nó sẽ tiếng Anh
của nó sẽ nói đó của mình thật Alo Được
chưa một cái đó comment một cái tài liệu
họ sẽ nằm trong bộ thẻ HTML cho sẵn rồi
Đầy thẻ hạ tầng là thẻ ATM và thẻ ATM
này sẽ ôm trọn những cái thằng bên trong
nó như này
được chưa Thì công sẽ thời là cái cú
pháp được chuẩn thứ hai mà có công cần
biết đó Cậu là ở mấy cái này
thì rõ ràng ở Sai báo cái thể hét này
nằm trong thẻ HCl thì cái thẻ đóng của
bé cũng phải nằm trong thể đóng của tim
em không không được đóng ở ngoài nghe ở
đâu nhá chưa thì các bạn mở thẻ ở trong
thì các bạn phải đóng luôn ở trong các
bạn không được đóng ra ngoài thì chưa
đấy cụ để làm nguyên tắc thứ hai
nguyên tắc 1 là
đề tài liệu có đầy đủ
3 phần
đó sẽ là phần 1
là khai báo phiên bản
phần 2
là ra đây phần 2 tất cả thể hẹn này bộ
thể hết
bộ thể hét
thể hét sẽ chứa
sẽ chưa Cái gì
chị sẽ chữa những cái không hiển thị cho
người dùng được chưa
những cái không hiển thị cho người dùng
những cái không hiển thị trong người
dùng nghe mông lung quá đúng không để
tôi thử nói cho mấy ông dễ hiểu hơn nhé
thể hết sẽ chữa những cái mà ví dụ là
thứ bảy tôi lên tra Google à
Ừ anh run ok Ô chẳng hạn như này
ở đây
sau khi mà Tra Google tìm kiếm như này
nó sẽ ra ngoài tên của trang web do ngồi
tên miền xong rồi nói chung mọi thứ như
thế này đúng không Các bạn thấy là những
cái hiển thị ra đây này hay những cái mô
tả đây này đúng không
Em chỉ là nằm trong thẻ hết nó sẽ nằm
trong thể hét để cho cái những cái công
cụ tìm kiếm như Google hay là Yahoo hệ
binh hay là gì Để Nhớ
a bắt bắt gói quà hàng tên Vân nó sẽ tìm
kiếm được
đi tìm kiếm được trang web các bạn nó sẽ
đọc
hôm qua bộ thể hét để biết được là trang
web của các bạn thực chất là lo gì vậy
chưa này
Ừ nè thể hết chưa những yếu tố đấy
Ê mấy ông Hôm nay đông hòa mấy ông vào
bảo bảo tôi đúng không Để lần sau tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ để chế độ cứ 5 phút thì ông trả
lời được một lần cho mấy ông đỡ phải
shop em chat nữa
Chào tạm biệt trung ở học nào có những
bạn đang lắng nghe và chỉ muốn học thôi
phần ba của cái HTML đấy nó sẽ là ba đi
đúng không sẽ không có phút không có
kiểu
em không có kiểu dạng là có đầu có thân
rồi Tại sao không có đuôi không có chân
Đúng không Không thực ra cái body là quá
đủ body nó sẽ
body chứa đỡ nhà chưa Ngược lại là chứa
cái hiển thị cho người dùng thế xong
đúng không thấy chưa có bạn thì sẽ thắc
mắc với mình gỡ là em để chữ Hello ở
trong này nó vẫn lên đây nghĩa thầy
chuyện giò đúng không rõ ra ngoài Hello
nằm trong head nó vẫn hiển thị trong
người dùng cơ mà không Nhưng cái này là
quy tắc của của nó đó là mình sẽ vứt cái
này vào trong ba đi chứ không phải là
mình chích vứt ở đâu thì vứt đúng không
vì giống như là lúc đầu các bạn thấy rõ
ràng là tài liệu này chỉ có mỗi chữ
Hello thôi nó vẫn hiển thị ra mà nó cần
gì phải có cả một đống bộ hè này làm gì
đúng không Nhưng mà mình không nên như
thế đúng không
Mình phải theo quy tắc của nó nghe chưa
ạ
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ đấy thị có bạn bảo tôi đang dạy rất là
chậm Nhưng mà tôi đang dạy toàn bộ những
cái cơ bản để các bạn thì xe lại và các
bạn sẽ không được thắc mắc mình mấy và
em yên tâm htl chỉ có hai An ba bốn buổi
thôi Thế nên là mấy ông không thấy Hà
nói chậm đâu những buổi sau tôi không
dậy lại kiến thức này đâu Mày không phải
thì hiển nhiên là hiểu và biết rồi đấy ừ
ừ
ờ ờ
ở đây Nói chung à
Thế Hiển thị trong body Ok Google thì
bây giờ tôi sẽ lướt qua tất cả những cái
tất cả những cái mà
họ như những cái bộ thẻ câu bạn để mấy
ông làm bài tập về chưa em
ờ ờ đầu tiên có bạn vừa rồi khác bác về
cái vụ utf-8 này đúng không Thì cái này
nó để thể hiện được việc là trang web
của các bạn trang web và các bạn nó có
chứa unikode và hiển thị được tiếng Việt
có dấu sự đây là xin chào các bạn và
thầy hiệu trưởng chị ạ Tại sao phải đi
ra như thế bởi vì có thêm những cái dấu
kiểu như này các bạn thấy rõ ràng nó sẽ
hiển thị được có dấu những việc là xử lý
xóa này đi nó vẫn hiển thị được có dấu
chứng tỏ là trình duyệt này thông minh
lại còn mất Sự thật là như thế Tại sao
mình phải nói trên giờ thông minh giờ
mình sẽ thử mở cái pha này Đấy copy file
không mở bằng máy đi con nghe ok
đi
tàu tao để mày ở đây để mà tao thỉnh
thoảng bêu xấu của máy lại kiểu thế
Sau đó các bạn thấy em có nhìn thấy cái
gì không Alo Đấy tác dụng đấy nhưng mà
các bạn nếu mà thêm cái này vào thì nó
sẽ hiển thị Đúng rồi chưa Nhanh nhiên
không ạ
Vì thế nên tôi mới nói đây là trình
duyệt thông minh à
Ừ hi vọng mà mày có shop không nghe được
mấy câu ấy
ừ ừ
Ừ ok Nói chung à Tôi có cất nhà xong mày
mày cái thế thôi để tôi ôm một đống bài
tập từ các bạn hãy hát tìm lời lẽ không
dễ để chúng ta nhìn sang bài tập chúng
ta sẽ làm này này
ở
bờ tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn làm bài này
đấy Kiểu dậy một cộng một bằng hai nhưng
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ làm cái bài như này
thế để làm được cái bài như này thì
ờ ờ các bạn thực tế khi mà làm đấy
sẽ làm một cái trang web
anh nói chung à Nói chung là để mình
giải quyết một bài toán vấn đề nào đó
thôi thì các bạn luôn phải nhìn một cái
tổng quan trước đã
anh nhìn và tổng quan sau đó thì mới đi
vào chi tiết cụ thể tại sao mình phải
nói tổng quan
bởi vì ở đây là
mẹ không yên tâm cái này rẻ lắm rồi chưa
tổng quan ở đây rõ ràng Các bạn thấy
trang web Nó là màu đen đúng không Tầm
quan mà màu đen thì mình phải làm thế
nên nó màu đen đã đúng chưa tiếp theo là
chữ chủ yếu là màu gì Đúng không chữ chủ
yếu là màu trắng mà Thì mình sẽ phải làm
chữ màu trắng đúng chưa đó
ở đây mình tôi sẽ hướng dẫn mày ông làm
này nhé
khi bé ơi Nói chung là các bạn thấy rõ
ràng đang nền tráng đúng không Đang nền
trắng thì đưa mình sẽ phải chuyển sang
nền đen mình sẽ có khái niệm là bgbl này
bằng Black Ừ thì khái niệm này thì nó sẽ
là các bạn phải cách ra một cái nhé các
bạn không được ghi sát ngay cái màu nó
khao bạn sẽ cách làm một cái xong rồi
gọi bg-color xong một bằng Sau đó thì
nháy sao mò thì tên của cái giá trị đấy
Đây là tên thuộc tính đó sẽ là thuộc
tính
nó Chipu Chipu u ạ sau đó thì giá trị
tất cả vào lưu cái chưa thì các bạn sẽ
thấy đó à Cái này có thể là
ngày như thế này hoặc cả ngày như thế
này đều được từ chưa nó không khác gì
nhau cả nhưng các bạn không thể nào làm
mở nháy bằng cái này say bóng nhà như
thế này các bạn thấy màu nó bị như này
không nó sai đúng không các bạn sẽ phải
có một quy tắc nó là như thế này thôi
Được chưa ạ
anh một lần như này hay là nhảy đơn về
chưa ạ
Sau đó các bạn thấy đến nó sẽ truyền qua
thành màu đen hoàn toàn đúng không Không
phải bị mất chữ đi mà chữ mình đang mà
mù màu đen nên là phải phải bôi và nó
mới thấy đúng không để chữ mình muốn
chuyển sang màu trắng thì mình sẽ có thể
khái niệm mà thể phone như này đó mình
sẽ ôm toàn bộ cái này vào trong này thì
chưa
các bạn sẽ thấy cách viết của mình cách
viết của mình ấy nó là
ẩm thực tế là các bạn có thể bị giết
đúng kiểu như này có ông biết kiểu đúng
kiểu Nga tất cả mọi thứ trên đúng một
dòng như thế này
Ô thế không tốt cách viết của mình sẽ
lại enter xuống dòng như thế này enter
xuống dòng enter vào bà cái này lùi vào
như thế này xe điện cái này để làm gì
cái cách viết code của mình ghi như này
để mà
Ừ để mà mình sẽ hình dung Thằng này là
thằng này sẽ là thằng con của thằng này
và thằng này sẽ là thằng con của thằng
này và để cho để khi mình quên đóng thẻ
như này thì mình sẽ nhớ là nó quên mình
quên nóng thẻ thì chưa vào Tại sao mình
dùng thể phun như ai Bởi mình sẽ có thêm
color thuộc tỉnh color nó bằng màu trắng
mấy ông mấy ông tình anh tôi nghĩa mới
ông đủ giỏi để biết được nách wai Nó là
màu gì Đúng không
không không lỗi lầm ấy ông kêu rút thì
anh quá đúng không
Tôi chưa
thế hiển thị ra à thế này được rồi đúng
không ạ
Ừ đấy thì
và đương nhiên là bài tập của tôi không
bắt máy Ông gõ lại tất cả các chữ này
đâu Bởi vì tôi có hạn file word để ở đây
mày không gõ rồi chưa ạ
ờ ờ
và Có ảnh nữa Nếu không thấy là rõ ràng
đây có ảnh bìa
Ừ thì bây giờ Làm thế nào để hiển thị ra
được cái ảnh như thế này đây tôi sẽ
chị sẽ chỉ cho béo cách để nghĩ tới cái
ai à
ở
đây mình sẽ có thể img này đó nếu mà tôi
dùng tôi gọi enter gái lập tức và nó sẽ
đóng thẻ hộ tôi luôn và nó xem thì ra kẻ
RC này RC này là viết tắt của ruột tức
là nguồn và đường là cái nguồn kéo cái
đơn dẫn để truy cập đến cái cái ảnh đấy
thì mình sẽ mở mình sẽ phải cầm có một
cái đường dẫn chuẩn của máy ảnh thì chưa
mình sẽ vào đây này copy cái đường dẫn
này giải dài tiếng khủng này nóng
ạ sau đó đi
già nó đây này xong sọc chéo phát nữa
tên của anh này
ngay để lấy được ảnh chưa
khi kéo Đúng rồi đấy á Không thấy tôi
phát Ông xã thôi Hơi bị chuẩn tiếng Việt
đấy à
ở gạch chéo sục chém xuống ruột đúng mặt
ạ
ừ ừ
đề thi các bạn nếu mà máy các bạn ấy mà
không có hiển thị ra cái chấm chấm get
này đúng không thì các bạn sẽ một là các
bạn phải biết cách mở nó lên mình sẽ
không chạy bây giờ mình sẽ hướng dẫn chị
nhiều ông không biết cách tìm máy hiển
thị ra cái á
anh nghe cái chấm đít này mấy ông cần
view này chưa ấn auchan ở đây này sau đó
thì view tiếp này sau đó thì tắt cái hay
extensions for know file này ăn ok Nó sẽ
hiển thị ra cái chậm get này còn nếu mà
ông nào chưa Không nhớ điều đấy thì chắc
là ông phải tự gõ thủ công chấm get đến
Thôi ngủ trưa đi
Ừ thì nó sẽ chỉ ra được ai còn chưa
mà các bạn sẽ thấy nhận ra một điều đó
là đương nhiên à cái ảnh nó khiến cho
chữ này nó không xuống dòng
ý thì cái xuống dòng thì vẫn đi học rồi
mà chính em B rồi đúng không ạ bây giờ
đỏ như thế này thì xuống dòng chưa ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ copy kể cái vuốt này
một tí đi thì sẽ copy Word để mà mình đỡ
mất công gõ lại đúng không
em sẽ copy một đoạn rồi nha À
à à
ở đại mình dễ thường 2a
ở Tab nó vào như thế này nhìn nó rõ này
nó được chưa
Sau
đó
các bạn thấy sẽ thấy nó khác cái ảnh win
winpower sau đó thì nó xuống giọng hẳn
cách hẳn của dòng ngay đúng không thì
các bạn thấy nó sát như này thì các bạn
sẽ phải xuống dòng Br2 phát như này trở
lại
thực tế là như mình đã nói là
khi mà các bạn hoàn toàn có thể
Nhi nó sát sàn sạt nhau như này vẫn chạy
nhưng thực ra là không nên như thế đúng
không Không nên như này mà mình nên khi
1 xuống dòng thì mình lên hpr xuống dòng
hẳn như thế này để các bạn Ừ để các bạn
cậu nhìn Cốt nó rất À tưởng mình rất rõ
gì chưa em
Ừ rồi Tiếp theo là mình muốn cho trữ và
xử lý muốn cho chữ à review
các video wordpad mẹ đúng không
Ừ để nó để nó kiểu
màu đỏ thì mình sẽ dùng cái gì lắng nghe
mình cũng sẽ dùng cái phone này tiếp để
đổi nó xong màu đỏ cũng chưa thì thường
mình lại viết như thế này cách viết mình
nhé Phone này
bóng hệ Phone này luôn mở rồi đóng được
chưa rồi Mình ghi cái gì phải ghi sau đó
đi color bằng led này đó mình sẽ như thế
này thì các bạn sẽ thấy là
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là rõ ràng là mình
có màu trắng nổi nhưng mình thêm ổ đỏ
vào thì nó sẽ không chuyển sang mẫu hồng
Nó sẽ không phối màu gì ạ Mà nó sẽ mà nó
sẽ kiểu hiểu là cái mô gần nhất với nó
để nó đổi thì chưa nó không phối màu với
Nga ông không phải ngồi học cách phối
màu đây những chị làm màu đỏ gì ạ Ông
chỉ cần ghi chuẩn nó sẽ là ra thôi
a tiếp theo là muốn cho nó gạch dưới
gạch dưới như này chẳng hạn thì nó là
thẻ and life tức là thể kiểu gạch chân
chưa mình sẽ là thểu and like Ooh này
mà đây lại Đồ ngu này
Em
hãy nhớ là đóng thẻ Mở thẻ ở trong thể
phone đóng hè nằm trong cái phone này
chưa các bạn hoàn toàn thể để u nằm
ngoài thấy phone xong rồi thể phone nằm
trong tùy Thực ra cái này nó nó chỉ ra
các bạn thích thằng nào trước thôi chứ
nó không ảnh hưởng gì lắm
ở Bạch tiếp theo nữa đó là mình muốn cho
nó in đậm thì cho nhiều Ôm biết tiếng
Anh và làm quá thì biết rồi có thể yêu
thì chả có thể b là thể Bun tất cả nó sẽ
kéo làm cho nên đập
em có bạn đang họp trước và bảo là dùng
đít hay các thứ thứ được không hay là
tại sao không dùng CF thì mình đang dạy
mình đang dạy do các bạn toàn bộ những
cái giờ cơ bản
ở những cái cậu dạng và dùng hết thuần
bằng HTML Còn nếu mà các bạn muốn xịn
hơn thì đương nhiên à về sau mình sẽ dậy
từ từ về chưa
đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó vừa in đậm
này vừa màu đỏ điều hòa
à à
ở đó sau đó thì bây giờ thì các bạn thấy
toàn bộ những cái dưới này rất dễ rồi
đúng không Tất cả tất cả bọn này dễ rồi
Ừ
Nó là kiểu chỉ đơn giản là các bạn chỉnh
sửa lại toàn bộ tất cả đống này đúng
không À cái này làm thế nào để nó xuống
đến đây thì có ông chị bê đơn giản biết
nhiều xuống đến đây thôi đúng không cái
màu này là màu ghi thì các bạn sẽ chuyển
chuyển màu nó dùng thể phone lại đổi nó
sang màu ghi đúng không và chữ này nó bị
bé đi để mình sẽ sửa chữa trả xử với
đoạn này chữ nó bị bé đi thì mình lên
làm như thế nào là xử lý balo một đống
xuống như này sau đó mình muốn làm chữ
bé đi đúng không
Thì mình sẽ dùng cũng phải dùng thể
phone thứ nhất là mình sẽ cho color nó
sang màu màu ghi thì sẽ đây này
Ừ
đúng rồi có bạn mà dùng hát 6 thứ cái A
thì nửa đúng nửa say 10h 6 thì đúng là
mấy chỗ nào bé đi giống như bạn bạn nhớ
bài tốt vết Hoàng vừa nãy mình có nói
qua h 6 lần chữ bé nhưng mà chị cái đấy
là biến in đậm hết bây giờ mình có cách
đó là mình dùng thể phone sau đó thì
mình cách ra thêm một cái nữa mình sẽ có
thuộc tính là sai ngay thôi mình mình
ghi sai cho nó sai và kích cỡ mà đúng
không
đề thi cái sai này mình nhớ không lầm là
chữ chuẩn chữ mặc định bình thường à sai
nhưng 12 14 thì nhớ để ba đứa mà thưa
các bạn không cần phải nhớ size của nó
chính xác là bao nhiêu bạn chỉ cần là -
21 - 3 như này được nó sẽ hiểu là nó -
so với mắc định là bao nhiêu Là được đó
như thế này bé đi rất nhiều đúng không
đó Thế thôi gì chưa
ở đó cây Quốc này là cái ảnh nhé Bây giờ
tôi sẽ đăng bài này lên để mấy ông mấy
ông sẽ phải cái ảnh này về sau đó đi tự
tự Cốt lại kể cái bài tập này nhé gì
chưa
ừ nó đó xong bài xong bài nhưng mà chưa
xong bởi một đâu tôi sẽ dậy luôn buổi
bài thứ hai trong mấy ông Jimmy ông về
nhà với ông làm bài 1 bài 2 phạm tôi
đang cả bài 3 đến mấy ông Nếu làm luôn
được chưa
à À mà có bạn để cập xanh ảnh đúng không
quên đấy
Ừ
thì mày ông Để ý kỹ ở đây đó là cái ảnh
này nó Tràm luôn cả các trang web mà bầy
luôn cả trang web đúng không ạ
Khi dòng cuối có chữ màu đỏ trứng màu đỏ
chính là mình lại ôm lại cái phone color
này cho các thứ thành chữ màu đỏ thôi
đúng không
Khi nào linh tinh Tôi có đăng cho cả cái
gốc này mày không gõ lại mà mày cũng
không cần phải gõ lại chữ đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ đấy thì làm thế nào để cho cái ảnh này
Nó kiểu nó sẽ kéo tràn ra như này thì sẽ
có khái niệm cách làm một cái này nó sẽ
là with
chẳng biết phát âm tiếng Anh cho này
không Thỉnh thoảng tôi phát ra những
tiếng Anh không chọn mà Mấy ông kệ đi
thì cái cái này nó là chiều rộng chiều
rộng
Ê mày không có thể rõ hẳn con số nào đó
vào đây để mà ví dụ là ông muốn cho là
100 Tết thì nó thực ra rất là bé còn nếu
mà ông muốn cho hẳn Cell phần trăm của
cái trang web thì sẽ là một trăm phần
trăm cả này
nó sẽ như này nó sẽ trang web của người
ông càng giãn ra như này thì nó sẽ cái
ảnh nó sẽ ko theo được chưa ạ
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà đây đứng nhờ công sẽ thấy
chúng sàn nhược điểm khi mà nếu mà dãn
ra quái ảnh nó sẽ bị vỡ bởi vì anh ở
đương nhiên độ phân giải nó không thể
không cam thế và đã cả là khi mà càng
giãn ra thì nó theo tỷ lệ của cái ảnh
thành ra là cái chiều cao nói nó cũng sẽ
được to ra nó sẽ nói chung là nó sẽ cao
Gọi to ra điều thế đúng không Thì nếu mà
ông muốn cố định cả chiều cao thì nó sẽ
là hai thôi đúng không Hay như này và
cái hay này thì sẽ
anh không theo phần trăm được các bạn
phải khai báo rõ nó là bao nhiêu thế này
chưa nó sẽ bị rụng 200 Tết chưa chắc ạ
Nó sẽ cố định như này khi mà các bạn
Thay đổi cái gì nữa thì nó vẫn sẽ cố
định chưa ạ
sau
đó thêm những cái mà các bạn cũng phải
biết
ừ ừ
Ừ tự nhiên ảnh này không để đẹp được
giống như ảnh bên này và các bạn sẽ có
thắc mắc một tí đó là tại sao cái ở đây
nó vẫn còn thừa cái khoảng trống màu đen
này đúng không Ảnh nó không sát sanh sạc
được giống như cái này thì cái đấy thì
phải xanh và chua có ông rất nhiều thắc
mắc địa hình ạ Tại sao chữ này nó lại
thủ phông chữ
áo phông chữ nó khác với phông chữ này
làm nó đợi được như thế thì học HTML là
chưa đủ các bạn sẽ phải học sang bên CS
về chuyên về giao diện để các bạn làm
nữa thì để các bạn hình dung được cái về
website
HTML là gì sẽ tờ gì Và ra quyết và gì
thì mình thường hay dậy cho sinh viên là
kiểu rất nhiều người đến tương lai ví dụ
htl nó là xương sấm của cái trang web CS
thì để cho nó trang điểm mà nó thêm có
màu mè của ra à có kiểu có da thịt tí để
các bạn nhìn thấy nó hấp dẫn và ra
Switch để khiến cho nó hàng cử động được
nhận được chưa Nó thể chuyển động được
đề thi HP pro không Nó khung xương nên
hàng ra nó rất là thu kiểu da xấu về
chưa
thì các bạn muốn chỉnh lại giao diện đẹp
hay xấu thì các bạn phải Thiện phải thêm
CS vào thì nó mới đẹp được thì chưa nên
là có rất nhiều cái nó sẽ không đẹp được
như hẳn cái bài tập các bạn không để làm
đẹp được như vậy tập cái hình mẫu nhưng
mà các bạn chỉ làm cần mức tương đối
thôi được
ok Đây là bài đầu tiên bài thứ hai thì
thực ra là nó không hẳn là khó lắm mày
thứ hai chỉ cần biết thêm một tí kiến
thức thôi Đây bài thứ hai ừ ừ
Ê mày thứ hai này cái thêm tí kiến thức
khi đó chính là thêm mỗi việc là làm thế
nào để ảnh này nó nó ra giữa hoặc là cái
cái này nó nhảy sang bên phải về chưa và
thêm gái ở dưới này tự nhiên có thêm
dòng kẻ này thì thôi còn đâu những cái
về cái này là ảnh này cái này là chữ màu
xanh này đúng không
Ừ cái này cũng lại ảnh này anh nói chung
rất nhiều cái ở đây là ảnh và nói chung
một mấy cái chữ màu xanh này
Ẩm Thực ra các bạn biết hết rồi có bạn
dùng thẻ Phong là đủ rồi đúng không nên
mình sẽ chạy quanh anh ở đây lại buổi
một thực ra nhắn mà đúng không
ừ ừ
thì mình sẽ
thì mình sẽ tạo một file mới đi trạm xá
mới demo 2 chấm Martin pro đi cũng htl
này à
Ừ thì mình sẽ chỉ dạy qua về những cái
mới đấy còn những cái những cái ở dưới
này mình không dậy đâu nhé mày cãi cậu
để mình đi ra như này mình không dậy nữa
được chưa
có cái ảnh này thì bây giờ mình làm thế
nào ảnh hai đứa như mình sẽ kiểu dùng
thẻ img thôi đúng không
emg này rồi à mình lại phải đúng đến cái
đường dẫn ảnh này Đừng giận anh sụp chéo
cho tên của ảnh vậy có đuôi anh nữa đúng
không Không nó không nhận cho mình chạy
thử nhé các bạn hãy ấn chuột phải vào
open in Brother nhưng với điều kiện là
các bạn lưu lại file rồi vào nó chấm
HTML thì các bạn mở được bằng trình
duyệt nhé Đây nó giảng các bạn thấy nó
không cần nắm giữ đúng không ạ
anh cái ảnh này để cắm nó giữa thì có
rất nhiều ông đang đề cập ở đây là
e-center để cân bằng giữa các thử thử
Thực ra vị bản thân cái ảnh
không thể dùng để ở like Center như này
được để khả năng giữ được Tại sao bởi vì
À cái ảnh này Thực ra nó là cái ảnh nó
không nội dung ở giữa để nó ăn cái nội
dung Đẩy ra giữa Thì bây giờ mình phải
chơi cái mẹo khi mình chưa biết CF thì
mình sẽ phải chơi cái mẹo này mình sẽ để
nó nằm trong một cái thẻ p chẳng ạ thể
PJ ạ
à mà thiệp p rồi nó sẽ căn ra giữa gì
này
gì chưa à à
à à
Ừ
thì các bạn thấy đây làm cái mẹo thôi
chứ về sau chúng ta không nên dùng cái
kiểu thô như thế này để căn giữa một cái
gì đó
Cái này sẽ dùng CS để mà
Ừ để mà làm vụ này nhà hát tim lồ nó
không có hỗ trợ người vụ đấy nên là mình
phải làm như như thế này phải chưa thì
tương tự thì các bạn thấy là bơ để trong
một cái chữ nó sang bên phải thì cá nhân
đó là dai đúng không nha
A là
Anh hello thế này sẽ nặn xong rồi như
thế này
thì nó sẽ cần phải thì thôi
ừ ừ
ở cái gì
ở đây sau đó thì cuối cùng là cái gạch
cái gạch dừa như này chỉ các bạn sẽ có
là HR còn như ông bảo rồi hl nó là viết
tắt của cái gì cũng không nhớ đâu Ừ thôi
Mày không thích hiểu cái viết tắt cái gì
mà em cứ tra nhưng tôi không quan tâm
Đấy Tôi không bờ
em không bao giờ quan tâm cái này nên
tôi không sao đâu ạ
chứ không phải quan tâm hết rồi buồn
cười à
ở đây đây đây đây là nói chung ạ Bài tập
2 thì nó sẽ nó sẽ có thể là nó chỉ thêm
mấy cái mới này thôi sao rồi bài tập thứ
nhất nhưng còn bài thơ thứ ba thì nó hẳn
so với trường phái khác
hình nền là cao ông thích thì thì tôi sẽ
cho ông xem qua bài tập thứ ba này nó
nhảy hẳn sang cái
khó rất nhiều thì buổi buổi sau mình sẽ
học bài về cái bài 3 này mày Ông đọc
trước thì sẽ đọc về Thay bồ trước cũng
được rồi chưa tôi sẽ không có nổi dậy
được và trong bộ hôm nay được chưa
Ê
mày không sao cái ra ngay mà không Nhưng
mà thực ra mình không biết cái đấy điểm
gì không Ai phỏng vấn Hỏi với cái cái vớ
vẩn đấy đâu
ừ ừ
anh làm sao để gạch đó súng cuối dòng á
thì các bạn Br nhiều sẽ sử dụng Nên cuối
dòng đương nhiên là đấy làm cái còn nông
dân như bây giờ dùng HTML để làm còn về
sau các bạn dùng CS để các bạn trình
giao diện là muốn nó nằm ở vị trí nào
hay từ thứ thì sẽ dùng CS để làm thì
thôi
em chưa
Linh mọi thứ thì mình để trong cái link
Tách cái bồ đúng không Đấy nói chung à
Ok kiến thức ngày hôm nay đã xong Bây
giờ chúng ta sẽ
Em sắp sang cái gì chúng tôi đã hứa ở
đầu video tôi sẽ chia sẻ cho các bạn về
you with cái này mới cái hai này mày
nghe thử em sẽ thấy hấp dẫn vãi chưởng
Ừ tôi lưu lại trong lót của tôi
ở đây hay cực trâu tố hiện chưa lưu cài
phần 2
xem xem thử
ở đây
ở đầu tiên thì các bạn phải hiểu Ui là
gì đã Tại sao ui ui thường ai đi liền
với nhau rất nhiều ông ở đây thì có nghe
chán thế này rồi là u zoo in the face là
giao diện người dùng và user experience
bạn trải nghiệm người dùng Tôi không ngờ
expel với nhau đâu thế Tôi chỉ nói nói
thế thôi nhé chấm đây đây à
Ừ Thì
ý thì cái bài này nó chia sẻ về từ cái
giao diện nó làm thay đổi trải nghiệm
thế nào Các ông kiểu gì không chẳng dùng
Google mát rồi đúng không có nhiều ông
thì dùng cả Apple Maps cô ấy bởi vì
thường Bây giờ ông nặng có cái iPhone
trên tay đi
ờ thì ờ
Ừ nhưng mà có ông có vẻ đồng tình việc
là Google Maps nó sẽ trải nghiệm tốt hơn
của Apple Maps Thời trước là như thế Bây
giờ tôi không biết được mấy ông như thế
nào nhưng thử cho chắc chắn là như thế
Bây giờ là nó được cập nhật thêm đỡ hơn
rồi khẳng định thế thì
Em
đừng bảo thôi Xong đường
xin lỗi ảnh ạ Ngoại trưởng với ảnh thì
xem bằng mắt à
à
à Không không cái này hình như ta từ
medium.com
a
VPN của
hai thí nghiệm medium Chặng Việt Nam
Việt Nam trận Liverpool Tôi không nhớ
nữa thành ra cái này nó bị chế ảnh tôi
bây giờ có thể mở web lên để làm ở VPN
lên để cho mấy ông sẽ mạnh nhưng mà tôi
sợ là nó làm đứt quãng stream làm cho
mất mạng
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí không thì tôi thời trang
cái tiêu đề này xem ông anh đấy Đang ở
chỗ khác không
ảnh
Minh Nguyễn
à à
Em
sợ anh này đang lại ở
Ừ anh đang ở chỗ khác thì nó lại
anh không đúng rồi
anh không không phải ông Vũ Nhật Mình
Anh
ở bài này tôi thấy hay cực bài hay hơn
mấy cái bài ở dưới này nhiều
Ê cái nhà tôi thử mở mở cái này lên 50
50 nhé
khi mở lên mà bị mất số sim là lỗi của
mày không nhé
à à
Ừ cái đậu xanh mở lên nó vẫn thế này à
i act as I put a ngồi chung một xe buýt
à
anh không vừa rồi chưa chạy được đâu
bình tĩnh Tôi chưa chạy được cái đấy đâu
nên mấy ông vẫn thấy đấy thì bị bay
nào phê rồi quên sướng nữa thôi tôi toàn
tắt mày cái trong ngoài đi thẳng a Đôi
khi phải mò để mở lại
grab mà tao e e
Ừ từ sử mặt tên tên của nó thôi nó crowd
này
à à
Anh ở mèo lại quay lại được buồn
vì nó không vẫn có dài nhỉ
hình ảnh ở bị bay rồi
Ừ cái nhỉ Bài 2 cực bài 2
Vì sao
à Tôi đang nghỉ bị bay rồi tôi thử và
madam xem được không nha à
a mi âm tôi bảo được còn ái ảnh bị bay
rồi
anh lính ở bài bài rất hay về
cho tôi tôi thử tìm phần 2 ra mà
ừ ừ
nghe
có phần hai của ông cá à
em
không nghe thấy có phần 2 của chính ông
này đang ở trên kia ba lô đấy
à à
anh không vừa rồi vào được mấy âm rồi
Chứng tỏ là có khi ảnh đấy bị xóa rồi
Ê thằng simple này dùng Media mà
Nghe ca nhạc
à à
ở đây tôi chả thử trên chỉ trang medium
nhé
em sợ mày có khi ở ghi trên này bằng
tiếng Anh
Ừ thế thì bằng tiếng Anh cũng được Thôi
để để gửi tra thử nhé
ở
phần 1 này sai này
medium.com này
300 chào ông ạ
à à
ở cây thật
ở phần bói của bản đồ cái gì anh ạ
I hear Cái này không đúng ngon hai cái
hai cái không
mở máy chưa
ở đây ảnh lấy từ
Ê
mấy ông vào vẫn ra ảnh hả
mà Tại sao tôi vào không ra được anh nhé
mạng Mạng chán à
ở
trình duyệt web code ok
khi dùng quá mày rồi mà nhỉ vào này vẫn
không ra
vì nó không dùng bằng cái gì
chị Thu quên sửa Mắt cách chỉnh mạng rồi
gì hết á điêu đâu hết
anh tin tưởng lắm nhưng AD nhé
à à
khi nãy Nếu mày lừa tôi
chém gió thôi Thực A B dùng trình duyệt
dị thế thôi Nó bị chặn có phải liên quan
đến trình được đâu
ở
đài để tôi mấy ông đợi tôi một tí một tí
thôi tôi sẽ chia sẻ cho mày nó về cái vụ
này
ừ ừ
cho quyền sử cách Về mặt cấu hình cái
bnf rồi này nó loạn quá rồi
ở thời dùng Win7 không tiện dụng
chứ không phải cái này thôi
thị trấn Đắk Tô
anh cũng không phải
ở đây Nhật Bản
ừ ừ
à à
A11 à 2888 nhỉ
3888 nhé á
à à
ở
đây đây là ok ok
Đã lâu rồi xin lỗi không
anh không dám tôi và chị ơi mày ôm cách
để mà chỉ đến đấy nhằm nhiên chưa
Nói chung là mấy ông thấy tiêu đề của bà
đang rồi tôi sẽ không đề cập lại cho ông
toàn bộ nội dung bài đăng này nó quá
thừa đúng không Tôi sẽ chỉ ông về cái
hình này thôi đầu tiên thì đây là hình
của Google Maps đúng không đến bây giờ
thử là nó vẫn thế này gì chưa
và tiếp theo đây là hình của Apple Maps
đến bây giờ nó có thay đổi một tí rồi
nhưng về cơ bản thì nó vẫn thế này cái
này Thời ban từ lâu rồi nên làm tôi đang
nói từ lâu rồi nhé Rồi chưa ạ
ờ ờ thì hai cái này đứng cạnh nhau như
này bê mấy ông trả lời chưa Tôi có hỏi
nhé Ừ cái khung mẫu cái cái này bên trái
là Google bên phải là Apple đúng không
cái không màu xanh là là là những cái
khung mà nó chiếm để mà mình bấm bấm
click để mà thực hiện lạnh còn màu trắng
là để hiển thị cái mát đúng không Thì
nếu không trả lời nhanh cho tôi này cái
thằng bên trái hai thằng bên phải hiển
hiển thị mát nhiều hơn thằng nào Theo
thẳng Hiển thị map nhiều hơn thế vùng
màu trắng hộ thằng nào nhiều hơn thảm
bên trái nằm bên phải
anh hỏi hỏi nhanh sợi nhanh nào
à à
sẽ có ngày mấy ông đều giỏi toán nha
Ừ nếu sang được
Ừ ok rõ hàm bên trái nhiều hơn đúng
không đấy Ở đây ông ấy có đi cập hẳn bao
nhiêu ký xe này rõ ràng phòng bên trái
nó hơn hạn chưa
Ê mấy ông nói bên phải là mấy ông fan
cuồng của Apple rồi
Mở bài Tôi sẽ không nói chuyện với mày
không đâu
nãy cái bên trái hiển thị hơn 7 phần
trăm Ok thì ra là nó cũng chẳng ảnh
hưởng gì mấy nhưng mà ý tôi đề cập ở đây
về việc là
A2 thẳng và hai trường phái riêng hẳn
hai hẳn hai mục tiêu khác nhau đúng
không
Ừ thì thì đây tôi sẽ thử nói cho ông cái
bài này nó sẽ thể hiện rõ về quan điểm
của thằng Google thế nào con điện Hoàng
Apple như thế nào thì trong bé uống hình
dung được chưa ạ
Thế thì thằng bây giờ Nói chung là lược
bỏ bớt đi nó sẽ có giao diện chưa quan
như này đúng không chỉ quan là mấy cái
nút là như thế này Đúng không mấy ông để
kỹ cho tôi mày kể mấy cái này từ
từ từng cái chi tiết một thì ông sẽ thấy
là ở đây có anh tìm kiếm ở đây cũng có
thanh Tìm kiếm đúng không Nút này Nút
này Tại sao nó lại có mấy cái nút này và
bên này Tại sao lại có mấy cái nút này
Đúng chưa đấy thì đầu tiên ở đây cái hay
tìm kiếm ông có để ý kỹ và các hãng tìm
kiếm này nó đi thẳng là Google tên của
cái hãng con xe ngày thì nó không thể
ghi thẳng lá cổ được ngủ ngon Nó phải
ghi rõ ra là bạn phải nhập cái gì đó để
tìm kiếm đúng chứ Đấy cái thằng này cái
trong thừa mày thằng vô ăn điểm bởi vì à
a Google nó nổi tiếng là gì nổi tiếng ở
Tìm kiếm thế nên là nó chỉ cần để tên đó
đây thì người dùng nhìn và hiểu được
ngay là bấm vào đây để tìm kiếm thân
Apple nó không thể ghi hẳn logo nó ở đây
là đây đã bồ được vậy nó sẽ chẳng hiểu
mẹ Apple là cái gì đúng không nên nó
phải ghi rõ là nhập cái gì đó vào đây
đúng chưa đây một cái mà Tôi thấy rất là
hai thằng One định điện tìm việc mình có
cơ hiện nay rồi mày không đúng không Tôi
đọc lại tưởng mình đã thôi
tiếp theo đó là
Ê thằng Google nó có cái bấm vào đây bấm
vào cái hình được tượng hay mưa này mãi
tôi biết đây bị tưởng hamburger vãi
chưởng để mà mở thêm những cái tùy chọn
đúng chưa ạ
Ê thằng Google nó nó để mở thêm những
cái gì đó thì nó sẽ nằm ở trong góc này
cũng chưa con để mà mở thêm tùy chọn của
thằng Apple thì mới ông dùng Apple rồi
nó không biết nó ở đâu không
Ừ cái mở thêm những cái tùy chọn khác ở
hình giao diện mới này thì nó bấm vào
cái nút nào
anh ở đây không mong nào dùng iPhone à
anh alo hay bị chậm răng
Á đù ngon y đúng không Đó nghĩa là nó
phải theo quy tắc của chuẩn của nó toàn
bộ hành của iOS đều phải có biểu tượng y
và info là thêm bấm vào cái y than để mà
thêm thì chưa ạ
sau khi bấm vào nút home i
bộ phim ở đây thi quy tắc của thằng is
luôn luôn là như thế nó là bấm lại để mà
thêm thông tin về chưa
tiếp theo là bấm vào vị trí của tôi thì
thì thằng Google nó là nút này và thằng
Apple nó như này Vân cái đấy bỏ qua
a tiếp theo ở trên này mấy ông để ý có
biểu tượng micro phone tất cả
kiểu ghi âm để mà tìm kiếm bằng giọng
nói tại sao thằng Apple lại không có cái
đấy Ở bên này ông biết cái biểu tượng
micro của của thằng Apple nào nằm ở đâu
Mấy ông dùng Apple iPhone nó không chia
sẻ để xe mà Apple Nói chung ấy Iraq nói
chung
i y là iPhone không phải là info đâu nha
mấy hôm tại linh tinh đi của IOS thì nó
là info mà à
Ừ đúng rồi nó nằm ở trong bàn phím Đúng
rồi theo quy tắc của thằng áp is bất di
bất dịch là nó luôn nằm trong bàn phím
nó không nằm ngoài màn hình thế nên là
các bạn dùng
khi dùng Apple thì các bạn sẽ phải quen
với cái quy tắc đấy nó khó hơn nhiều
đoạn soạn lên đấy do thực ra nhiều người
đã bị là người có tuổi ở người ta cũng
rất thích dùng dùng Cài Apple là bởi vì
nó luôn theo một quy tắc bất di bất dịch
nó không bao ở đổi loạn cái nút nên nó
luôn mãi ở đấy đấy quy tắc của nó là dễ
học dễ hiểu
300 hỏng không hẳn là dễ học mà chẳng
qua là dễ nhớ thôi nó không Bụng nó
thường không bao giờ thay đổi một cái gì
đó
thì nó sẽ Đôn cố định ở đây
và một trong những cái của nó nữa là nó
khoe mà Vic khoe với cái hệ sinh thái
của nó thế nên là nó luôn có nút chia sẻ
ở trên cùng nó luôn thích về việc và
chia sẻ thông tin này xanh
hai iPhone khác hay à iPad 2 cái gì đó
hệ sinh thái của nó thế nên là nó sẽ
hướng có cái nút chia sẻ ở trên này cho
dù mì Ông thấy là nút này nó chẳng liên
quan gì trong công việc tìm kiếm của ông
cả nhưng mà nó thích cho nó có quy tắc
bất gì với dịch là như thế con thăng
Google thì tôi đã nói bởi vì phòng gỗ
nóng lạnh là tìm kiếm mạnh cả về nhận
diện giọng nói nên là nó thích để ở đây
để thể hiện khá Mạnh vì Tìm kiếm đúng
không đây đấy là nó qua với cái việc là
cái màn hình này đã thể hiện được việc
mỗi thằng có 2 cái cách xử lý hai cái
mục tiêu khác nhau rồi đúng không ạ
khi đó ở dưới này nó đi cập hết này tôi
sẽ không nói lại đâu thằng
Mì ông mà không xem hình ngày mà không
biết được mẹ tỉ lệ mà như anh muốn xem
hình ảnh mà nó biết mà
Tại và ở khi bấm vào cái hamburger bên
trong này nó mới đi ăn tất cả rất nhiều
cái nữa này đúng hoặc của thằng Google
thằng Google nó rất mạnh vì tìm kiếm và
nó có rất nhiều thông tin nữa nên là nó
nó có rất nhiều cái này thằng Apple được
à Bấm vào nó cũng chỉ có thêm một vài
cái thôi ông ạ ạ Bây giờ thì nó có nhiều
hơn rồi nhưng mà Thời đấy nói chuyện mua
vài cái thôi
ạ bây giờ nha
a tiếp theo là đến việc Ok bây giờ nãy
giờ chỉ với giao diện đúng không Bây giờ
thẳng vào vấn đề tìm kiếm này Alo thẳng
về thao tác này sắp xếp và bố cục này
cái này thực là tôi đến thấy ghét cái
ảnh này điểm mà cái ảnh người ta bị
ngược bây giờ Google lại nằm bên phải
con Apple nằm bên trái
Ừ cái này thường ra thằng cu gọi lại
đang bị cũng thật là nó đang cố hướng
đến là cho người dùng dùng điện thoại
bằng một tay được và thiên về bên tay
phải
Ừ tôi không biết là có tùy chọn để mà
chỉnh Chỉnh xanh có thể cho các bạn tiện
tay trái không nhưng mà các bạn thấy ở
đây rõ ràng là các bạn dùng bằng tay
phải để mà lướt để mà quét bằng ngón trỏ
nó tiện hơn bằng 1 tay thay vì thằng
Apple lúc nào phải cầm hai tay để mình
để mà kiểu lớn lớp cái gì đó
Anh ba đang nói về mỗi cái map này rồi
nhé đó các bạn thấy rõ ràng ngón trỏ các
bạn muốn bán lại lướt hết bởi vì lướt
kiểu xanh cháy xăng
anh nói chúc em bé ông hình dung được
ngón trỏ của mấy ông có thể vuốt vuốt
cái này dễ hơn so với kiểu bên này mà
đúng không đúng chứ
ở đây nó có lý do mà nó đi
Nghe nhạc xem cái này mình cảm thấy hay
đi
a tiếp theo là thằng Google nó còn thêm
cái tìm kiếm là tìm kiếm gần đây này Hãy
tìm kiếm theo cụ thể hiểu
Ừ kiểu như này đúng không
Ừ ăn ngón trỏ ngón cái nhỉ Chẳng biết
anh đón đi Con cá à
Ừ ăn con cá xin lỗi có thêm một thông
tin nữa à
Anh xin lỗi xin
Ừ cái ngón trỏ và ngón gì nhỉ từ trước
là mình nhầm ngón à
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi thằng Google nó thêm những
cái tìm quanh đây này xong rồi còn thêm
cả những cái những cái thông tin nữa
đúng không ạ
Ừ nhưng mà đây em ấy chỉ phần 1 phần 1
thôi phần hai nó mới để sâu hơn này chưa
xong phần 2a
cha mẹ ông ấy bắt đầu đi xa vấn đề đấy
Tôi chỉ nói thế để biết mày không có
đang tập trung anh không thôi
ừ ừ
có ai Xanh phần 2 phần 2 này các bạn sẽ
thấy da
Ê thằng
cho tôi tôi bỏ qua hình này tôi cho mấy
ông thẳng đến cái hình này
à Đây là hình
à À đây đây đây đây là hình mà khi các
bạn tìm kiếm cái gì đó ở trên Google
Maps thì chưa
các
bạn sẽ gõ tìm kiếm này sau đó thì nó sẽ
kiểu hiển thị thêm một cái hình ở đây
nữa đó là cho các bạn có thể tùy chọn
được các bạn muốn thực sự đi đường nào
là kiểu có rất nhiều đường cho các bạn
chọn ông muốn đi đường này thì có thể
thời gian tăng lên này các thứ này và
màu nó các thứ nữa thì chưa sau đó thì
nó mới cho mình đi chọn đi con hình ở
dưới này mấy ông thấy rõ ràng à Nó chỉ
có một đường cho ông duy nhất thôi bà nó
chị con đường như ai thôi mấy ông sẽ
nghĩ ra ở nó chị tao con đường ngắn nhất
thế là đủ rồi nhưng thực ra không Thằng
thằng Google thì nó ngon hơn là điểm là
nó có đầy đủ thông tin hơn để hiển thị
ừ ừ
Ừ thì nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ hiển thị ra là
đường nào chỗ đoạn nào tắt và có thể gợi
ý thêm được nhiều nhiều nữa thằng Apple
Maps đến bây giờ thì nó có hỗ trợ phần
đấy rồi nhưng mà đương nhiên nó vẫn
không thể nặng mạng được mà Thằng Google
Maps nên thành ra bây giờ rất nhiều ông
mặt tiền ứng dụng hàng ai phụ iPhone
Apple nhưng mà vẫn dùng Google Maps quá
đi
Ừ đấy Ờ
Ừ đúng rồi thằng Apple là chiều thằng
Google ở đúng mỗi cái này đúng
Ê bà nó không thể đề xuất ra rất nhiều
về lộ trình con đường như này nó chỉ có
một đường như này thôi đúng không
ạ Và bây giờ một trong những cái điểm
khó chịu mà
ở đây đây thử thử thử hỏi những cái ông
mà chị không dùng iPhone nữa tội không
dùng iPhone những Tôi không biết đây dụ
ạ bấm vào cái bấm vào vị trí này không
Ừ nếu dùng Google thì ông bấm cái nút xe
này để hiểu là
ý là chỉ đường đến đấy đúng không
Ừ nhưng mà bấm vào cái địa điểm ở đây
này thì ông ông biết phải bấm vào đâu để
mà chỉ đường đến cái nào
Em bấm vào nút nào để chỉ đường này ạ
chị sẽ che từ ca nó hơi chậm Nhưng chắc
là phải đội tím
hai nút góc xá là rồi
vé máy bay giấy này là bấm về vị trí của
bản thân
xe tải mấy ông đái mấy ông còn không
biết nói cái gì không ạ ấn vào cái bản
Dài dài này thì nhảy sang xem review này
Ừ đúng rồi nút xe này nút xe mới ra này
nó bấm cái ô tô là mới ra mà trong khi
đó rõ ràng là cái mình tra tìm kiếm để
mà
Ừ
để mà mình chỉ đường đến đúng không
Nhưng mà không thằng Apple nó vẫn phải
theo quy tắc là nó thích thì việc là nó
tìm kiếm chia sẻ thông tin nó quan trọng
với thông tin nên nó bấm vào đấy xem
review rõ là cái phần review này nó
chiếm quá quá hết đúng không
Ừ cái này mới là cái để mà bấm vào để mà
tìm kiếm vị đường đi này và đây là xem
review
Ừ đấy thành ra là cậu rất nhiều người
khó chịu với cái này đứng nha bây giờ
Apple nó thay đổi tội Tôi không dùng
iPhone Nên cậu không rõ
Ừ nhưng mà Đấy đúng rồi có bạn kia nói
đúng đấy Đó là cho cái review to mà thực
ra là mình vào map để mà tìm kiếm không
phải tìm kiếm cái cái đấy đúng không ạ
à à có rất nhiều ông sẽ bấm nhầm vào đây
đúng không rất nhiều ông sẽ bấm bấm vào
đây đúng không hoa có bấm ở trên này đi
Bấm cho em không đúng đâu nhé phải bấm
lời này anh thấy rất khó chịu không
Ừ đấy nhưng mà đây cái chiến thuật của
Apple nó lại là cái bài toán này
sẽ dễ học hơn là dễ hiểu tất cả sao
những là các bạn làm quen với việc học
một cái gì đó ở trên sử dụng trên Apple
đấy toàn bộ hệ sinh thái của của nó sẽ
giống hệt thế nên là các bạn chỉ cần học
một lần các bạn sẽ hiểu và Lần sau các
bạn dùng được hơn là dễ hiểu tức à hiểu
được nhanh nhưng mà thực tế thì nó bị
nguy hiểm đây cái nguyên lý này nguyên
lý longpress Đó là nguyên lý như thế này
bơ tôi Giả sử tôi có hai ví dụ cho ông
mới này à
anh có hai nút xóa
một nút bấm Phát xóa luôn không bao
nhiêu
khi mà một nút bấm
thì nó sẽ hiển thị thêm một thông báo
xác nhận xóa
bấm xác nhận rồi nó mới xóa
trong trường hợp này ông nào thích cái
nút bấm phát ở luôn Ông ở thích bấm xong
phải sang nhận
anh trả lời tôi có mày xem
à à
Ừ cái bài toán ở đấy mà ông đang tự
nhiên là đang nhiều ông thích cái dưới
hơn cũng có ông thích cái trên sao cho
một phát ăn ngay rồi lười Thằng áp cổ nó
luôn theo quy tắc nó long-press đã hai
phát mới được
Ừ nó là một thứ rất tốt cho đấy do mà
tôi vừa nãy tôi còn đề cập đó là người
lớn tuổi người ta thích dùng hàng Apple
hơn Friso cả bởi vì người ta
em sợ đôi khi bấm nhầm và một cái gì đó
thì không thì hoàn toàn là thằng hát Hồ
nó luôn xác nhận thêm một lần nữa mặc
thêm một cái yếu tố lên người dùng bớt
lưỡng lự vì việc là họ bấm ngâm Còn cái
việc thằng Google nó tiện đây Tôi cho
ông xem vẽ hình
Ừ cái hình ở đây không sẽ thấy
mô hình này
32 hình này nhá hai hình này thôi
32 hình này
anh xuống đây
ờ ờ ờ
ở trong đầu nó ngon anh xuống đây
Ừ ông sẽ thấy ở đây
ờ ờ cái bên trái là của thằng Google ấy
bên phải của thằng A Phủ
Ừ đúng nhỉ
Ừ đúng tối không nhiều lắm
Ừ đúng rồi đúng không
Bộ tai nghe này
Ê thằng Google nó hiển thị tất cả các
nút ở trên chứng một trang và ông bấm
nút nào nó cũng nhận thằng Apple Nó chỉ
có một nút thôi Bấm nút này nóng thì chị
ra những cái nút khác thì
Ừ Thì bài toán ở đây đó là thằng người
dùng ở bên trái nó sẽ luôn là cân nhắc
thì bấm đúng nút bấm sai nút thì nó lại
mất công ngồi quay ngược lại như nào dẫn
mệt con Hằng ở bên phải thì nó bấm một
nút nó mới nhìn thì ra nút nữa cơ thể cứ
thể làm người dùng cảm thấy chắc cũ hơn
và tin tưởng hơn thằng bên trái gì làm
người dùng phải suy nghĩ kỹ trước khi
bấm bấm bấm nhầm thì thôi
Đấy đấy đấy đấy là bài toán mà thẳng
Google nó hướng đến khác với bài toán
của thảm áp hồ nó hướng đến
Ừ ông hình dung Hồng đây thằng thằng
Apple nó phải bấm một nút rồi nó bị thêm
những cái nút như thế này chưa Còn thằng
Google nó một phát nó hiển thị một đồng
nút trên một trang luôn đấy Bây giờ ông
bấm huyệt cái có nhiều không biết quay
lại như thế nào
gì đấy
cho nên là đây gồ thì nó đang đi ngược
định luật khít này đúng không Mà ốp trần
anh đều làm con người cố định chậm lại
thì thế nên là tất cả giải quyết bằng
một trạm 1 bấm vào xong hết Cũng chưa
con Hằng Apple thì nó lại theo phương
châm là 2 click mấy giải quyết một vấn
đề để cho người dùng luôn suy nghĩ kỹ
lại trước khi bấm gửi béo tay nhanh lên
não nặng đúng không đó
hôm nay mấy ông thấy bài viết này hay
không cái này nó đánh mạnh rất mạnh về
cái trải nghiệm người dùng qua cái giao
diện qua giao diện qua giao diện mà Mấy
ông kiểu gì mấy ông chẳng dùng rồi đúng
không Thì nên tôi thấy bài này phải rất
hay về us
anh ấy còn nội dung mấy ông muốn đọc kỹ
hơn tôi ăn bớt rất nhiều mà ngon mấy ông
muốn đọc kỹ hơn mày ông biết từ khóa tra
rồi trên keepall mày mà rất nhiều và rất
hay không phải dân công nghệ đọc vẫn
hiểu đúng không để cái hay của cái cái
blog này đi
khi con bé mẹ không phải dân công nghệ
ông không đúng không đọc mấy cái này vẫn
hiểu mà nghỉ à
ở đó Hôm nay video cũng gần hai tiếng
rồi Thế mà vẫn còn 300 người xem Chứng
tỏ là tôi không nên nỗi tệ lắm trong
buổi đầu
cho tôi biết tôi sẽ mang lại bài tập các
thứ thứ để lên trên mấy ông Bỉ phần mô
tả của mấy cái video này thì tôi thương
ai
Ai Cập nhật trong phần mô tả Để Linh các
thứ Nếu họ nhé
Ok hôm nay thì không có thể thêm thời
gian để trả lời câu hỏi các thứ nữa buổi
sau tôi trả lời vậy nhé đi
Xin chào mấy ông